the following is a conversation with
george st pierre considered by many to
be the greatest fighter in the history
of ufc and mma but even more than that
one of the greatest martial artists ever
quick mention of our sponsors all form
expressvpn
blinkist theragun and the information
check them out in the description to
support this podcast as a side note let
me say that getting the chance to hang
out with george talk to him on the
podcast record a quick self-defense
video that i'll release soon all while
both of us wearing suits was one of the
most memorable days of my life
in setting all this up i talked to joe
rogan and originally we couldn't
schedule a chat with him and george on
the jre
which allowed me to pretend for a brief
time that george came down to austin
just to see me
who the hell am i
in truth him and joe probably conspired
to make me feel special but that's the
point it's inspiring to see george and
joe
who are at the top of their field treat
others as equals as human beings no
matter who they are
even silly russians in a suit
meeting george was an honor for me
beyond words
this is a lex friedman podcast and
here's my conversation with my long time
martial arts hero and now my friend
mr george sampire
in your fighting career where you're
more motivated by the love of winning
or the fear and hatred of losing i like
to win better than i hate to lose
because if it would not have been the
case
i would never have fought in the first
place because i don't like to fight at
all
but you talked about the anxiety the
fear that you experience leading up to a
fight so
to you ultimately the reason to go
through that
difficult process is because it feels
damn good to have your hand raised
there is that there is also the fact
that
martial art i've been introduced when i
was very young and it's probably the
best
thing i can do in my life fighting it's
that's what i do best
also it provides me
of freedom
of access of things that
most of people do not have
but all that as a price and a lot of
money i made a lot of money of course
with it
i was
maybe predisposed with certain abilities
i
met incredible mentors
throughout my life
i worked really hard
and of course i had a lot of chances the
the stars were all aligned
and
in order to to kept keep that those
advantages
of freedom money and glory and excess of
things that most people don't have and
have the these
dream life that i have
i had to sacrifice myself and fight in
order to keep it
it's very hard to understand
because i also believe most fighters are
not like me
they a lot of guys because i
corner a lot of guys and it seems to me
that they love their job they enjoyed
to to go fight in a cage i love to train
i love the science of fighting the sport
the to to be in good shape the
confidence that training in mixed
martial art give me
however i do not like the feeling
of uncertainty the stress
that i have
not knowing if i will be
badly injured
or
humiliated or
winning the fight it's to me unbearable
and it
that's what takes the most out of me
more than brain damage more than
anything that's what takes the most out
of me
but the thing you get from it is the
freedom
that you get
because uh because of the money but
because of the celebrity because of
everything that comes with it so you can
be the best version of yourself because
of fighting but at the same time you've
said that
quote i don't believe there's pleasure
in life
i believe there's only a relief from
pain we have to suffer to be on top
so isn't there something to just the
suffering in itself just doing really
difficult [ __ ] just to get to the top
to explain that and so people can relate
to it because not everybody is a fighter
i think
the best example i can
[Music]
gives is
let's say you're
you haven't eat for a long time and
you're craving right so you're suffering
and then when it's time to eat finally
you're about to eat your favorite dish
it's gonna taste so much better
so that's why i believe
there's always a some sort of sacrifice
before the pleasure and the more
sacrifice you do
like they say in fighting the bigger the
risk
bigger is the reward and i feel that's
that's how it is for me yeah i feel that
with uh i've started fasting a little
bit in the past couple of years and uh
there's nothing as amazing
as a delicious meal or anything actually
anything any food when you haven't eaten
for several days it's it's kind of
incredible uh it's not incred it's not
incredible in this simple way of finally
i get to eat
it's you get to truly experience the the
beauty of of
what it is to be alive like that little
piece of food you see
all the flavors
you you you feel just the experience of
it is uh ultimately
of gratitude of how awesome it is to be
alive
but when you eat many times a day and
you're pigging out and
you don't get to experience that and
it's fascinating it's re it's really
like fasting
is one of the most accessible things for
people i think to experience that kind
of
uh pairing of hardship to pleasure
i agree and
in my case it changed my life on a good
good way i cannot recommend it to people
because everybody is different
but
after my
to to fight michael bisping my last
fight was against uh
the champion in the heavier weight class
that i used to compete at so
i thought that
if i would gain weight
it would increase my performance yeah
and i struggled a lot to gain weight i
gained a lot about eight to 10 10 pounds
normally i walk around 185 pounds and
for that fight i was walking around 195
however
i forced myself to eat like six times a
day i was on a very
strict diet and i didn't feel
it didn't feel right to me because
i feel like i
i was carrying like a little bit like i
was carrying a bag on my shoulder
and
i think it was a bad idea for me
because when i
did the weight the weigh-in and i i go
went on a scale at 185 i couldn't go
back to my initial weight that was 180
195 that i worked so hard for several
months to get there
so i was 190 pounds but i couldn't get
back and the morning of the fight i i i
got i got sick i had like uh
we didn't know what what it was and the
beginning
because in order to know to find out
what it was i needed to do what they
call a colonoscopy they put a camera
inside of you and to do that
they give you um
[Music]
something that makes that empty you and
i was trying to gain weight not to lose
weight
so i i told myself
i'm gonna wait after the fight whatever
it is because it was pretty bad it was
blood and i i didn't know what i was i
was very concerned concerned i thought i
had maybe cancer i was freaking out
so i said i'm gonna do that fight and
then after right away i'm gonna make a
checkup so i did that fight everything
went well i won the fight i went back
home i did a colonoscopy and i i got
diagnosed with ulcer colitis
then i got on very severe medication
to get better and i'm not a big fan of
medication i was trying to look for more
natural way to to
to get better and i found out about
fasting
and
it really changed my life i met dr jason
fong
was one of the
one i'm one of the world authority of
fasting he treat diabetes patient with
fasting
and he gave me a program of fasting
and
it really changed my life and right away
what i did is i went in in a cat scan
to see the difference because it was
right after my fight with michael
bisping and i i did the cat scan so i
had
my uh muscle mass bone density uh fat
percentage water retention it's pretty
amazing it can show you which harm has
more muscle than it than the other it's
very precise and i did it like uh two
two months after
yeah so i i started doing um time
restricted eating uh sixteen eight but
right that right away
when i started i did three days water
fast and the doctor jason funk says
because i like to train during those
days
i cons i consume himalayan salt to make
sure because when you sweat there's a
lot of minerals to to make sure you
don't depleted your mineral
and um
when i went when i compare the two
results in the cat scan i found out my
biggest concern was to lose muscle mass
i found out that i did not lose muscle
mass instead of losing it i it increased
a little bit
even though my
weight on the scale
was lighter
i i kept the same muscle mass even
increases a little bit my bone density
increases a little bit
my water retention is the biggest thing
that decrease so the my inflammation and
my fat percentage so basically the
by looking at the data i found out that
by eating
so much trying to gain weight for to
fight michael bisping i only increases
my water retention which is not good
because it's like dead weight and
inflammation on you
so what uh
was the actual process of fasting she
said 16 8
time restricted so intermittent fasting
but you also mentioned the three out of
the three day water fast what did that
feel like and you also said training
during the three day yeah how did that
feel oh can you give me some details of
absolutely this is fascinating so i do
three days water fast
uh four times a year nice for me i do it
everybody is different but for me i do
it after uh new year's because during
the the early days that's when i i eat
bad foods and i drink i see it more like
a like a cleansing you know like a like
like a detox so to speak mental too like
psychologically yes i do it
after the new years right before the
summer
cut for the beach yeah
yeah yeah after the summer because of
the summer i've been partying a little
bit sometime let myself go and right
before the the holidays
and um
i've tried the doc dr fungi says to me
say george everybody is different
because i'm a very active person and
everybody has a different genetics so so
for me i i feel that
three days is the sweet spot
because i still train during those three
days the first day the first two days i
don't change nothing i i train regularly
on every on my regular schedule however
on the on the third day
i modify a little bit i i do something
more
[Music]
more easy
and that's how i do it and i've tried
before because i when i say three days
is my sweet spot i've tried to go up to
five days but the problems is after my
third days i i found out that i had a
big problem sleeping i i get into a
hyperactive mode yeah they call that the
hunter-gatherer uh
mode you know like you you you you your
brain i mean it's amazing your
creativity is at its peak
but you cannot sleep very well and
sleeping
for me i think it's very important so
that's why i do three days for me it's
my sweet spot that's interesting you're
right it's the four or five days when
you start
see sleep is not important for me so the
creativity is really important so it's
very interesting with the places your
mind goes after a few days you're right
but uh
i mean what does it do to your mind so
you mentioned your body likes it in
terms of training does it um
do you find that it helps you focus and
think i mean you're one of the
great strategic thinkers in terms of
martial arts does it help with learning
does it help with thinking does it help
with strategizing and all that well
unfortunately i got into fasting
after i retired i wish i would have i
really wish people
asked me would you have done it during
the time that you competed and the
answer is yes
i think we live in a society that
we're bombarded by publicity oh buy this
eat protein
this that and
fasting nobody makes money with it
because there's nothing to sell you know
i think that's why
a lot of people have not heard about it
and even my for myself if someone would
have talked to me about fast the
benefits of fasting
when i was training before i got sick i
would probably have ignored
ignored him because it i'm not you know
it was
it's hard to believe sorry it sounds
ridiculous
yes it's going to help your mind and
you're going to gain muscle potentially
exactly and and
perhaps people have talked to me about
it but i kind of it went in one of my
hair and got out from the other side you
know
but uh it really changed my my life and
dying i i was diagnosed with ulcer
colitis and
it helps me get rid of all my symptoms
what i do is i know a lot of people have
ulcer colitis and and
for me i cannot recommend it to to other
people because everybody is it's
different but for me
i made a a lot of research of how people
from those circulations got better and i
found out that a lot of people that got
that condition
get better in the natural way fasting
eating fermented food collagen
and like bone broth and stuff all i got
and it made a huge difference in my life
i just wish i would have known that
before so do you have a specific diet
wise
stuff you like so you know i've recently
another ridiculous sounding thing but it
makes me feel really good it's very low
carbs so
you know keto even carnivore it sounds
ridiculous it doesn't make any sense but
it makes me feel really good even for
performance
is rogan has an influence you know he's
a no carnivore diet i was influenced
actually by people yeah well he
there's i'll tell you where cause i was
doing it before he was doing it uh is
there's it was uh popular in the
endurance athlete community
where it was fat adapted athletes it's
people who insane people who run 50
miles 100 miles
they figured out that they could fuel
their
body by
with fat they can go to fat as the
source of energy as opposed to carbs so
and i remember
hoping that i'll be able to learn how to
run 50 miles and so on i've never done
more than 22 but
it i i just remember
switching away from carbs
and feeling really
liberated like i wasn't thinking about
food as much i'm able to eat once a day
and feel really good i mean it i think
every everybody's body is different but
i think carbs make me lazy
maybe it's because uh
yeah it's the crash but also just
psychologically something
it uh it forces me to also think about
food too much like it starts becoming
you know art just like you said our
society is so much about food there's so
many so much advertisement and so much
of our social life is about food and so
it's very easy to live life
like live day to day thinking when is
the next meal like what am i gonna eat
for lunch what am i gonna eat for dinner
what am i gonna eat for breakfast
and uh
if you're not careful that's going to
get in the way of you doing cool [ __ ]
for like
liberating yourself and thinking like
what am i actually passionate about in
this life like creating and forgetting
to eat those kinds of things and still
being able to fuel your body i don't
know it's been fascinating
to to figure out like later in life that
carbs aren't necessary to function well
it makes me think like we don't know
anything about nutrition that's right
yes
you know um
personally
i
don't think i could have a diet without
carbs i love chocolate too much
for me eating it's a it's a pleasure of
life i love my carbs i love my sugar
however if you talk about that i don't
have a specific diet
but
recently i
what i'm trying to do is
the days that i do not work out
i only eat
once
that's kind of my rules plus i try to
respect
sixteen eight and do my three day fast
four time years and but the rest of the
thing i i
i i let myself lose because i i don't
think i would be happy if i if i uh
if i if i don't give myself the the the
right to to eat for me personally i love
to eat so much next and um
you talk about diet carnivore diet is
very interesting because i
a few years ago i went to africa in
masai mara and
it's a tribe in
in east africa
and
i went to visit them i did a safari
and i talked to them
and these guys they their diet is 99
carnivore they that's crazy and you
should see they're very beautiful people
shredded like yeah some people would say
oh it's genetic i'm like yeah maybe it's
genetic but i mean
and think about the eskimos also that
like most of their diet is on on fish
right they so
i believe it can be done you know like i
believe it can be done like an exclusive
carnivore diet and i
i think i'm gonna try it pretty soon
just to have the experience you know to
see how it feels like where you're gonna
hang out with joe
be careful bringing it up because he'll
convince you to uh forever switch to
carnivore definitely he loves it i mean
but just like you
i think he loves
food so he's he can't ever stay on
carnivore it was funny because we went
to an italian restaurant together and i
still only eat meat like i love um
i love the constraints of discipline
that's that's partially why i like
carnivore i like saying no to food that
is delicious
[Laughter]
but a part of the problem is that i
don't know how to moderate you said
chocolate i don't know how to have one
chocolate is that something you're able
to do
have like
in moderation no it's when it when i
have an opportunity i do it i don't have
any i'm an extremist person alex i i
that's the thing i
when i when i have a chance i i like i i
just eat i go too much and that's why i
like about my life you know that's what
i like about fasting because probably if
i would not have discovered fasting
eating chocolate would give me cramps
and all sorts of problems yeah because
people on ulcer colitis normally they
cannot eat chocolate they cannot drink
alcohol but i believe
because i'm fasting that's the reason
why i'm i'm medication
medicine medication free i can eat
whatever i want whenever i want but i
have to do that that fasting you know
and now it becomes to it became to a
point that it's no longer hard for me
it's it's like normal i don't even force
myself yeah i don't it's easy you know
what i mean
some of my friend thinks i'm think i'm
i'm insane you know
but i tell them it's like with when you
get used to it it becomes like an abbot
and i'm and i know that hunter-gatherer
like our ancestor did not eat three
times a day it's it's
it's not true they they ate when they
they could and when they eat they they
they
they feed themselves as much as they can
until that because the next time because
they didn't know when
they could eat again right
so it's uh i think that's how we're
we're built you know to to to have this
similar lifestyle
if we could take a step back to the
discussion about fear a little bit so
mike tyson talks about
this process of him walking to the ring
he sounds similar to you in many ways of
the anxiety and the fear that he
experiences
and uh he has this uh
sort of story that he tells about
walking to the ring and being supremely
afraid
but as he walks and gets closer and
steps in he finds the confidence and
becomes supremely confident i think he
calls himself like a god i feel like a
god in the ring
is is do you go through a similar
process of finding the confidence
well it yes
and um
i usually i use a james lange theory
they they did
so what i do is because i'm i'm
i'm not afraid to admit that i'm afraid
and uh
in the beginning of my of my career
i really thought i asked myself
because i was very good
in mixed martial but i i i really
thought i wasn't made for this because
the idea of fighting didn't
was was didn't make me happy it's
something like i i was i was forced to
do in order to
keep that lifestyle that i have
and achieve my goal perhaps one day to
make enough money to retire and you know
that that was my dream
but when i was looking around
the gym where i was training most of my
training partner they were happy they
were excited and sometimes i corner i
corner a lot of guys and they're happy
and they're in the locker room they
don't react the same way i do
some perhaps
does but
if you see me in the locker room
like when i get like my last fight with
michael bisping just to give you an
example in my last fight with michael
bisping
because it's fresh it's the one that is
the most recent
and but it's always the same thing my
last fight
and my thing i get in the locker room
i had like
three guys that i trained with mickey
gall emin zahabi and uh joseph duffy
they all lost it was like like my locker
room was basically cursed
you know the when you're in the locker
room and
people from your locker room leave for a
fight and then they come back it's kind
of a momentum you know you you shake and
yeah good job now it's my you know it's
kind of a team brotherhood sort of thing
so the
the the
the atmosphere in my locker room was
pretty bad it was like uh going to a
you know like a funeral
so i was very scared and ever before
every fight i i asked myself i i asked
myself always [ __ ] what the hell i'm
doing here why did i choose to come back
oh my god and i'm freaking out
however
i'm putting on a mask
like i'm acting
because if i don't do that it will
reflect on my coaches and if my coach my
the confidence of my coaches is affected
it will reflect reflect on me so i need
to feel strong
i need to make them believe that
i'm excited to be there and i'm happy to
be there so this sort of play
start when i get when i first step in
the locker room even though i feel
completely different but that's how i
play it
normally the day the fight day i never
felt
feel 100 i always feel exhausted tired
my highs are hitching because i don't
sleep enough the few nights before
because i'm constantly rehearse
rehearsing scenarios that might happen
and i find
so
mentally it's not that
i'm not on top but you keep all that to
yourself i keep it to myself and i'm
lying to everybody around me
but everybody knows you know
for us john denahar they they know
freddie roach they've been with me for a
long time so they know what's going on
but at least i'm lying to them i'm like
i'm feeling great so and seeing all my
training partner
like very disappointed because they lost
their fight some were were badly hurt as
well
it was hard so and i remember i get i
get more i get
i start to warm up and everything and as
you start to warm up
you become a different person
because you know
certain we know that certain posture and
yoga can have affects your men your
mental state but it's i would say it's a
little bit the same thing in in fighting
you know like when you start hitting the
pads you your your muscle memory your
instincts comes back and and you
remember that you're good at this you
know and your confidence start to grow
and as seeing your trainers holding the
pad and repeating your moves
it makes you also remember all the
sacrifice you have done through your
your training camp and
confidence come from how you prepared
yourself and even you're afraid you can
be confident confident in the same time
being afraid and being confidence is two
different thing
and before every
fight just right before i walk in
it's when i'm scared i go in in the
bathroom
and i look at myself in the mirror i
used to have a bandana and a ghee but
now i it no more i didn't have this this
for my last fight because of the
the the new reebok deal they had
but i did the same rehearsal that i
always do i look at myself in the mirror
and i start to complement myself like
even if i don't believe it
i'm starting to trying to believe it as
i am i'm finding all the reason why i'm
going to win the fight
and and all my trainer knows that before
every fight when when the guy from the
ufc goes and steppen maroon says saint
pierre are you up next i always take a
few minutes to do that that same
rehearsal and i tell myself i'm gonna
win this fight because i'm better and
and i'm very cocky about myself i'm
telling all the reasons that i'm gonna
you know when i'm i got a better team i
made more sacrifice you know i'm i'm
faster i'm more powerful way more
athletic my fighting iq is better than
him i got a strategy on point that he's
never going to be able to keep up with
and and this and that
and i'm and be i was telling myself hey
i'm going to show these young kids how
things should be done you know i'm
trying to boost myself yeah yeah try to
to boost yourself and you start to
believe in it you become a different
person so when you walk out the bathroom
now rock and roll now
i really believe it for real you know
like i'm still scared but i believe it
for real and that's the transformation
that happened for me right there and
from that from now
from from there to the fight it's until
the fight is over it's called i call it
cruise control
because i do not have time to think in a
fight if you're trying to think you're
missing the opportunity so that's how i
see it for myself so at that point you
stop thinking and you just go cruise
control autopilot trust yourself you
know trust yourself because you you
repeated all the scenarios you know so
everything that you have done it's it's
inside that your computer your computer
your brain is programmed to react
accordingly to certain situations
and the it's not the the night of the
fight that you you'll you'll tell
yourself oh finally i'm gonna do this if
you do this now now if you have not
practiced it before you're screwed
it the preparation the repetition that
makes it happen you know what about like
the really difficult moments in a fight
where you
are tested to your limits essentially
usually it's cardio related exhaustion
right where you have to ask yourself
that same questions like why the hell am
i doing this
yeah
do you do do you experience those or are
you able to ride through the autopilot
and if you do like what do you do in
those moments never in a fight when i'm
in a fight when it's the the when the
fight is is on i never change my mind i
go
until the end
however
for example my first fight would be
japan
i had a terrible first round so i had to
switch gear
that happened sometime but it's part of
my plan i always have a plan b plans
plan a plan b plan c
you need to have that if fighters goes
into a fight thinking oh what i'm gonna
do this is this and they don't have a
plan b if this doesn't work that's mean
they're not well prepared if you talk to
me before every fight i can like in 30
seconds give you my old strategy
you know for for bj penn my first fight
would be japan was i'm gonna keep it
standing up
keep the fight from the outside you know
because i'm faster than him then the
fight would be japan's start i found out
that i was not faster than him and i
found out that
his reaction time was better than than
than mine so
i got beat up the first round and i got
the bloody nose and everything so my
plan b was now i'm gonna wrestle him you
know i'm gonna wrestle him and
you know make him tired and trying to
put him down and that's how i beat him
because i switch gear you know but if
you can't do that if you cannot find a
way to become the perfect nemesis to
your opponent you you you might win if
you fight but you
you're gonna find a uh you're gonna
fight someone sooner or later that will
that will give you a lot of uh uh a lot
of trouble so that's where the anxiety
pays off you're anticipating all the
ways it goes wrong so you develop the
plan b and plan c
hi you know we talked a lot with uh
like john donahue who you work with it's
interesting i don't think i've heard him
talk about plan b and plan c he usually
has a really clear plan a
an entire system of plan a i don't think
i've heard him we've had uh we had a
a good discussion about it in um
uh over some cheeseburgers
and he's uh he was kind of espousing the
value of mastering escapes so
when you find yourself in bad situations
being exceptionally good at finding ways
out of those bad situations and that's a
way of dominance
there's nothing
there's no better way to dominate your
opponent according to him than to show
that they can't possibly hurt you no
matter how bad the position is
uh it's like it's a as opposed to a
physical dominance it's a psychological
dominance it's very interesting
but i wonder
if he has plan b and plan c in his mind
too
you know in uh mixed martial arts
sometimes it's like in science something
you can make a mis like a mistake you
know like
every human can make mistakes you know
there's certain sport or a certain
situation that you
if there's a mistake made you're you're
you're that's it exactly sometimes it's
the case in mma
but sometimes you able to redeem
yourself
and uh
if you look the fight with bj pen
one that i had which was probably one of
the most competitive fight i and it was
probably the it was the fight that i got
the most
damage
and i was messed up it took me three
days like two three days to recuperate
from that fight i was really damaged
and my first fight versus my second
fight i made a lot of adjustment because
i i've learned from my first fight
and also i had a guy
one thing people don't know like they
talk about fighters having secret
weapons see for me my secret weapons was
not
like some is that they used like certain
like different things for me was
knowledge
i had a guy in montreal he was measuring
frames he's not a scientist is he's a
friend of uh ferrous and i and what he
does he you watch fight
and he measure frames the way he does it
is when you watch a fight and one of the
guy throw a punch he cut the picture by
frame the video by frame
so he's able to see
which fighter has better reaction time
than others
and bjpen he found out that bjpen penn
evolved the ufc roster at the time when
he was in his prime he had probably the
best reaction time of all
according to him lyoto meshido was the
second one
but bj penn was the first one so
i knew that if i would try to go first
because i always been the fastest guy
normally when i fight someone
but when i fought big japan i tried to
go first and he was always able to
like i never was never able to to touch
him with my jab and he came back with a
counter punch
however
because of what he told me i knew that
big japan has a very fast reaction time
but had a very poor reset time
to him the way he described it to me is
like your nervous system is like a
muscle
bj pen was so fast but he's like more
like a sprinter so what i did the second
fight i when i fought with japan i made
him flinch like i fake a lot so i make
him react and flinch so all that that
reaction time
that he used to flinch
was not used properly to avoid my
punches so he i burn i i load up his his
nervous system with a lot of information
and fit and fake and to make him flinch
and pretending i was kicking and
wrestling
so he got overwhelmed and he got tired
very very fast
so that's how i beat him people
sometimes they don't know really what's
the strategy behind the thing they only
see the physical part but when you fight
someone if i fight you i look at you in
the eyes
there's a lot of things that going on
between you and i i can look down here
pump jab you in the face
the audience will not see this little
detail
but you will see it and that's what it
makes the magic during a fight the
relation that you have with the opponent
you know like like the mental game what
you you make him believe those little
things i use
a lot of those if you talk to a lot of
my opponent they'll tell you like i use
a lot of these little thing you know
like i look down a banana i go i go up
or i'm pretending i want to attack you
so i'm i'm making flinch but in reality
i'm just doing this
because i want to rest i want to
recuperate and i'm tired
how much is you know people talk about
that with poker for example how much is
the value of this
you know so like some people argue that
poker is more about the betting
you know it's just the money it's just
how much you bet and so on so that would
be more
like uh the analogy there with with
fighting would be just strictly the
physical movement of your body and then
a lot of people argue that there's a lot
here in the way you look in the little
movements in the face so do you think
there's do you think you're
communicating with your opponent when
you look at them
there's no way to know for sure 100 and
i'm by no no mean psychic nothing like
that and i don't believe in that at all
the only thing is i know to
looking through the eyes of my opponent
when he's afraid and when he gives up on
me yeah i've been accused very often in
my career
to not take enough risk to not finish my
opponent but the reason why i didn't
finish my opponent is because i saw in
his eyes that he gave up he gave me the
fight and i'm winning the fight
so
it's not up to me
it's not to me to make it to try to
sacrifice myself trying to finish him
perhaps if i do that i will open up
from for him to to
to capitalize on my mistake
it's up to him to make a risk
so people sometimes they they don't
understand that this is the art of
fighting my friend you know like if i'm
winning the fight like in aki and isaac
if you're winning the game and it's the
third period
it's at the end of the third period
you're not gonna take out your
goaltender trying to score another goal
because winning
uh
uh five to three or five to four
is the same thing same thing in mma we
make a living out of this
and sometimes
you know as sad as bad as it can be you
want to save yourself for another day
you know you want to minimize the damage
but
if he knows he's losing the fight it's
up to you him to take the risk it's not
up to me
so i'm having i'm a good counter fighter
i use a lot of my attack or counter
strike or uh
reactive techno proactive take down
that's my specialty so i'm not gonna i
i'd have no desire to sacrifice myself
trying to to trying to finish my
opponent if he want to
if if if perhaps i might give him the
opportunity to capitalize on me
it's it's not it's not smart to do that
and very often when i fight someone i
can read him i see the fear in his eyes
now i'm like i got you now he's very
desperate that doesn't mean i have to
put my guard down because he's getting
he's going to be desperate but i know
i'm beating you and i know i'm beating
you i'm just going to do what i need you
know if i have a chance of course i'll
knock him out but i'm not gonna try to
sacrifice myself to knock you out
and if you do that
maybe one day you'll make a mistake and
you'll get dropped and you're you'll
you'll tell yourself i shoot i just
got brain damage maybe i'm never gonna
come back the same maybe you know i i
ruin my career or you know it's a it's a
very serious
game that we're playing it's very
dangerous
in the face of that
risk
i mean uh mike tyson talked about you
know when the opponent looks away
he knows he's got him
right that uh that
he's broken
for a person like me who
has trouble making eye contact with
people there's there's truth to that i
mean there there's truth to that that
there's there's an animal nature to us
looking away i mean you could see that
the way the body language the way the
eyes move between two animals going at
it
uh in in the wild when like two lions
fight or to whatever fight
there's a certain
beta move when you've you've been
defeated yes or one thing when i know
that that when it happened one of the
sign
is when i just like made a faint and the
guy flinched like crazy that's mean he's
really scared of me it's a little bit
like you're you're you're you're doing
this that guy flinch a little bit or
you're doing this he's flint like
that's mean you hurt him
and he doesn't want to get hurt again so
he's really trying to run away and
not
not winning the fight anymore but not
losing sort of surviving the the five
round and it's hard to to finish a guy
who does doesn't want to fight a guy
who's not fighting anymore to win and
he's fighting to not lose and the proof
of that if you don't believe me just
look the reign of all the greatest
champion in ufc i don't care who they
are jon jones or
uh
like you could clearly see that in the
beginning of their rank they could you
know finish a lot of their opponents the
same as me in the beginning i was
finishing all of my opponent but there's
a time that the entire ufc roster is
studying you
and they found ways to perhaps not
beating you but they found a way to
navigate to
the the fight in a way that they
minimize the damage you know what i mean
so it's a big difference between
fighting to win and fighting to not lose
you said that there's a difference
between a fighter and a martial artist
so now we were talking about fighting
you're considered by many to be one of
the greatest fighters of all time but
you've said that there's a difference
between
a fighter and a martial artist a fighter
is training for a purpose he has a fight
i'm
i'm a martial artist i don't train for a
fight i train for myself i'm training
all the time my goal is perfection
but i will never reach perfection
so what do you does it mean to be a
martial artist
martial artist is because that lifestyle
that i have has been introduced to me
and the seed has been planted to my mind
a long long time ago by my father
i am
i do not train
because i have a fight i will always
train even now it kind of amused me that
to see that
a lot of people because i'm still
training because i love the science of
fighting i do not like to fight but i
love the science of it and i will always
do it as long as i can do it
people think i'm going to make a
comeback and everything i'm i'm about to
get to have 40 years old you know like
it's
i have you know like
well mike i want to fight in a cage at
40 years old i mean some people have
done it they did it very well but i i'm
not one of them i'm i feel a little bit
to me that
and you never say never
i feel like to me like it's a little
like a kid that you play with this train
when he's young like
he's five years old brother six years
old or seven years old eight years old
and then i was like
what the hell i'm doing here and i'm too
old for this like i said i i
have done it you know and and and i got
out of it
on top and i'm i'm healthy which is the
most important thing right now i'm
touching wood and i'm i'm wealthy
i beat the game you know what i mean in
a way like i that's not to be cocky but
i did it and i wish more
more fighters could do the same thing i
wish
but
it's unfortunate because a lot of them
they stay there and hang out for too
long and and they get badly hurt they
get
beaten and and and broken you know and
they finish broke as well because the
lifestyle you have when you're a pro
athlete it's crazy you know it's it's
it's unbelievable
however everything that goes up in life
goes down and you need to plan your
future you know so
for for me what if some guys have the
same mentality as me and they're
watching us right now i would say
if you do it because you're just good at
it you like the money the the advantage
the freedom that it gives you but you
don't necessarily like to fight
when you're done you finish on top you
know
go go cash out and get out of here walk
away this is hard to do however lex it's
not everybody that does it for that
reason some people generally love to
fight love to compete so they do it
because i love it you know or they do it
because of the money but if you don't
love it if you don't like to fight
because it's very stressful and you
don't enjoy you you enjoy the training
perhaps but you don't like to fight you
do it because it's part of what you need
to do in order to keep that lifestyle
yeah and
you know like
you don't need the money get out of here
man if you're in your you're in your
prime get out of here because if you
don't you you you'll hurt your own
legacy your damage your your health it's
it's very sad and and
it's a it's a it's a sad business you
know what i mean i i
it's like a lot of uh
one one of the place where is the the mo
the mo one of the most happiest place
for me to go and the most the saddest
place for me to go it's on the gym to
try sorry montreal because it's one of
the happiest place for me to go because
i can go train and do what i love to do
but it's also a very sad place for me
because after when i'm about to leave
there's always a bunch of young kid that
comes or guys that are around 30 33
years old and they come to me hey george
you have some advice for me
and i look at them
and
if they're my friend they're real close
friend of mine i'll tell them the truth
in their face and i've done it many
times and it was not well received but
if they're not my friend i have to you
know
you know there's always an advice about
fighting and i answer their their
question it's my pleasure but the truth
if they
they want me to tell the truth
the big majority of them
i would tell them i said listen man
you're in a maybe a three like an a on a
losing streak of three fight
you're
30 33 years old you know i think you
should think about doing something else
in your life you know have other goals
you know because
you're not gonna make it and you know
i've seen that movie before and it's a
very sad ending
and i'm i'm sad to tell you the truth
because
you're not going to make the money just
choose some but if i tell them that
they're going to be angry at me because
they're going to be like oh you you make
it and you think i cannot make it so
it's kind of they're going to think i'm
cocky
but i was lucky to make it you know what
the star were all annoying but at one
point you need to be able to
to have a plan b you know like like some
parent they come to see me with their
kids
hey this is the future world champion
and then in ufc and what advice would
you give him i always tell the same
thing and it doesn't not make everybody
happy when i said i say i go to the case
say
are you good at school
say stay at school school is very
important for you stay educated yeah
do boxing martial arts a great sport
stay in shape
but don't put your eggs all in the same
basket
and the parents sometimes are angry when
i'm not angry but i can see in their
eyes they're like
they kind of
surprise
and
it's not because i made it that i will
tell their kid to follow the same path
that i did i went to school too i i've
studied
i i dropped off school when i had my
first world championship fight against
matt hughes
but before that i was school so i had
another you know a a a a another way to
go if things would not have gone the
same the the way i wanted
but the problem and i'm saying that it's
not only about boxing in mma i'm talking
about hockey basketball baseball same
same thing maybe it's the one on the 100
000 that make it and i'm saying
i'm saying that make it when i'm saying
make it that's mean they can retire and
have enough money for the rest of his
life because
it's a sad story the only people only
heard about the people that makes it
but a lot of fighter even a ufc champion
in boxing champion even in football
basketball i don't i don't care the big
names when they retire they have zero
they're bankrupt my friend and it's a
very sad
sad story and a sad reality that most
people are not aware of
but having other paths in life actually
can also
increase the chance of you
dominating and like reaching the highest
peak uh in your main thing i mean jimmy
pedro i don't know if you know who that
is as a judo coach in uh
in america
he was uh he says that to all of his
athletes is to make sure that you go he
has a lot of you know kayla harrison
two-time olympic gold medalist he has a
lot of uh olympic medalists but
basically there's something about going
to school like having a
forget school any other avenue in life
that gives you the freedom to go all out
in your main
like that you know you're doing it for
the right reasons you're not stuck
it clears the mind to where you're free
to be the best in the world yes as
opposed to
kind of you have to i mean different
people are motivated by different things
so sometimes some people like
having their back to the wall and that's
the only option they have but
most people i think excel when you have
other options i think it's a distraction
and i think it's important to have a
distraction
uh when you say that i think about one
of my coach john danaher he put his
academic background experience into jiu
jitsu and that for me that's why he's
the best teacher i ever had he's
incredible
he started
teaching me when i even couldn't speak
much english at the time and i was able
to communicate and understand you know
that's how good he is
but i i
truly believe that most of athlete
especially in sport like mixed martial
art
trained way too much
if i could go back
and talk to a young george i would tell
him say
you do way too much volume
you train way too hard train smarter
it's more important
and i think sometimes we
underestimate the benefit of uh
recuperation
because you i think we assimilate the
information that we learn
during a training
when we recuperate and not during the
training itself
and this whole mentality of harder
heavier you know like like
it's
it's good for someone who's lazy
but if you're an elite athlete most of
the time you know like you're not always
but most of the times because you're not
lazy
and a lot of guys sometimes they're
elite athlete
champions and you hear people say
oh i can't believe he's very gifted but
he doesn't work but perhaps it's not
really because perhaps it's because we
don't understand perhaps he's doing the
right thing and it's us
who's working too much and too hard
that's what i think
there's a guy i train with he's uh
he made me think about about it his name
is mansoor bernawi he's going to be a
future star is he's an incredible
fighter he trained once a day
and he asked me some time advice when he
came in montreal he's from france you'll
hear about him he's he's very good
and
i i saw him in the morning at tristar
and i said okay i'll see you perhaps
later in the other 20s oh no i only
train once a day
and he kind of wait for me to give him
like like like not not an approval but
like
to see how i react or or you know i
don't know
it was kind of a strange feeling but i i
told myself at that point i kind of i
had an awakening and i and i told myself
man
maybe he's doing the right thing
because a lot a lot of people would say
for example oh that's a lazy way of
doing it but perhaps it's the best way
to do it i'm not saying training once a
day is the the best way to do it that's
what i'm saying i'm saying that
everybody is different but for him it
works beautifully and i wouldn't change
anything you know like if i would be him
because he is improving like crazy
yeah and ultimately the bigger picture
there is to do something that everyone
else's uh says is stupid it's like the
fasting thing
that that a lot of people would say a
lot of nutritional experts would say
that that's
that's a dumb way
you know if you want to be an mma
fighter you should be eating like many
times a day you should be starting every
day with oatmeal you should be carbing
up constantly
but that's not necessarily true for
everybody and it's possible i'm sure
there's actually now a few mma fighters
that are carnivore only it's possible
i i used to eat
right before training and i it didn't
bother me
however now
i
my first training
that i do normally in average around
noon 11 a.m
i'm uh i'm
i haven't eat anything when i do my
first training and it feels to me that
i'm much
i'm much more clear and much more clear
in my mind i'm much more creative
i feel better yeah yeah it's a big
difference i just wish i would have
known that before you know well it's
fascinating the role of the mind and all
this how important
is it for your mind to be clear to
really think deeply i
there's a
there's a judoka american named travis
stevens i remember he said something
that
the right kind of practice is when your
mind is exhausted at the end of it
that you were constantly thinking
through things
like your body shouldn't be exhausted
first your mind should be exhausted
first
it's really fascinating so people think
about training hard
you know a successful practice is where
you walk away
just overwhelmed how much you have to
think
it's fascinating framing of
of a successful practice it's true
travis stephen was one of my main
training partners when i got ready for
my fight with
nick diaz and carlos conditt
he drove
every
friday
from i believe boston
it's like a six hour drive
drive
to the gym in montreal
train with us
an hour and a half
drive back
he's got such an amazing discipline i
was so happy for him when he won the
medal at the olympic game man
what a well-deserved uh
you know uh accomplishment it's
unbelievable it paid off you know i'm i
was so happy for him and every time we
we got to the the gym it was waiting for
me in a in in in the kneeling position
like a soldier
i was like my god this guy he's made of
steel you know
and and after training i always have to
offer him i say hey travis i know you
you you like to train with that because
in montreal they have very good judo
team nicholas gill and all that that was
guy
and i say if you want to stay i'll get
you the hotel you know like every
anything you want is like no no i gotta
go back i have another training later
i'm like not only that he trained with
with us he had to go back because he had
another training i'm like this is insane
and he's gone through a huge number of
injuries so he's also an innovator
because
i
mean it's difficult to say but for
american judo there's not many
high-level judoka so if you want to be
the like
fight with the best in the world you're
you have to be alone it's a lonely
journey actually it's kind of sad uh
it's much easier to be in japan where
everybody's a killer when you're alone
at it it's uh it's a difficult journey
and you know it's it's funny we talked
about
kind of there's some sports where a
mistake
is um
that's it you know you can't recover
from a mistake i think judo oftentimes
is one of those sports and added on top
of that
is um
the olympics
only every four years
and travis's story he's the reason why
uh when i saw him in 2008 as i i started
martial arts uh i switched from like
wrestling and
street fighting
to doing jiu jitsu and judo
and i just saw so much guts and the in
2000
i might be messing up the years here but
in the next olympics he fought
and he lost
on just the referee call yeah and just
he went to war and he just so much guts
and just
everything on the line and to lose and
then to still persevere through all
their injuries to all that through
incredibly difficult training sessions
to go another four years and then
compete and then win a medal i mean that
guy is just
and like he clearly could have been very
successful
he's also an incredible jiu jitsu
competitor so he could have switched to
that but he's stuck
in in
a lot of sport
when you're in elite
like for example in canada i saw he's
the number one sport in the country
kids when they're in elite when they're
young they get chosen and they're kind
of already
um known as a superstar you know in the
the school where they go and on the
program they follow like i'm sure it's
the same thing in us and basketball
baseball perhaps uh
american football
because they already chosen so they grew
up with that uh that it that itsy kid
that that uh superstar stardom so to
speak and it's already gla glass sort of
glamorous you know
however in
in mma there's no mma judo
wrestling like in america because it's
not our national sport it's it actually
it's it's not like
even when i first started was not really
well received by the media
there's no glamour into it
now i don't know it seems like it's
another era now
and i feel sometimes
that some people do it for the wrong
reason
you know some people
do it because of the glamour because of
the money
but even if you're an elite and very
good the glamour and the money
won't come
in the beginning
it's a very long grind
before you know it start it start to
come in and you need to make those
sacrifices and it's a it's a journey
that where you will be tested you will
be hurt
repetitively
and you're gonna have to to
reach the down deep and come back up and
then once you finally think you made it
you're gonna go back in the down deep
again it's a very exhausting and
decorating um
adventure sometimes but if you hold on
to your dream and you believe in it
you know and you have the the the stars
are aligned you're gonna make it
that's why it's only a few people that
that make it you know
and and um that's why i feel i feel
sometimes
the new a lot of people in the new
generation do it for the wrong reason in
my in my generation because a sport at
first it was there were no rules
i thought it was more pure the people
that did it was really
because of the passion that we didn't
seek money and
fame
we did it because we wanted to be i did
it because i wanted to be the man you
know i i like
to have the confidence that when i walk
somewhere i'm you know i have the
confidence that you know it's an
illusion because nobody is faster than a
bullet yes
but i wanted to achieve it for myself
and i
which today now because i don't know if
it's social media and all that that
the world has changed
the glamour the you know it's i feel
it's a different thing right now
yeah the uh if you get in it for the
glamour or the money you may not have
the right the right amount of fuel to
persevere through all the ups and downs
yeah sure you know when you talk about
motivation
of uh money and glamour
the a guy comes to mind and i don't know
how many wrestlers you know but
in russia
there's a guy named uh beauvoisiers of
the city of brothers one of the greatest
uh freestyle wrestlers of all time but
he also has um
it's funny he doesn't have many
interviews one of my goals is to go out
and talk to him in russian do an
interview with him because he's
exceptionally poetic and a deep thinker
he's uh the kind of martial artist that
you are in the way that it's not just
about the the different battles he's
been through or whatever it's about the
philosophy behind the way he approaches
life
and he he's spoken quite a bit about
that the the glamour the fame the money
are all things that get in the way
of um
the purity of the experience the art
that the way to achieve greatness is to
just
lose yourself in the art of the actual
combat in this case it's wrestling and
then
kind of not to worry and actively make
sure that you block out anybody who
you know
feeds you the narrative where you're
supposed to be this famous person it's
all those kinds of things that he
basically says let others write your
story
i
make sure that you just focus on the art
and now another person from that side of
the world is of course khabib
so he represents that side of the world
and we were talking about walking away
and most people not being able to walk
away at the top
as you have but also now
could be has it looks like
incredibly so so i mean maybe you can
comment about what your thoughts are
about uh khabib nurmagomedov being able
to just walk away you know we talk about
the goat very often
khabib is you know one of
isn't the argument because
he has
the most dominant carrier of all martial
art guy
you know some guys can be named the goat
for different reasons but khabib for
that reason and he's undefeated he'd
i don't even know if he lost
he might have lost round
but he'd dominate all his opponent it
was ridiculous
and such an incredible career that he
had
um
i love to watch him fight he's
incredible um
and when you talk about the art when you
say mixed martial art
the idea
of a
flawless performance for me
everybody often when we say flawless
performance thinks about a knockout a
brutal knockout
but for me it's
it's to be able to showcase
beautiful technique
like a beautiful take down beautiful
submission be like something beautiful
that
you know when you you look at
for example uh
wayne gretzky or
michael jordan or
like stephen curry or
even if you don't know nothing about
basketball and you watch michael jordan
you'll be like wow that's beautiful what
you just did
like we talked about fighting and and
trying to say
the the word beautiful and fighting for
certain people it could sound kind of
crazy you know but but i'm talking about
the technique
a beautiful technique
you know for me that's the goal you know
when i was fighting it's not only to to
have a brutal knockout because some
people are more gifted than others and
so i'm saying gifted some people are
better than others in certain
phases of fighting
but for me it was that it was to
showcase to win of course but to
showcase
some beautiful technique that that you
can watch the watch it and be like wow
that was incredible the timing he did it
that
and
when i talk up when i think about kabir
norma gomanov
i see all the detail that that of his
work especially when he got he's got his
opponent against defense that's like
that's his area of expertise where he's
to me he's the best that ever did it in
in terms of
that
fighting style that that particular
expertise that he has it's just
the the flawless execution of that
particular set of techniques yes
conor mcgregor had the the accuracy
the spider anderson silver was like was
i would say the most flamboyant of all
you know like he was moving like the
matrix
john jones was incredible in terms of
creativity spinning elbows and that and
he faced incredible
adversity
symmetry johnson was
so complete you could you could bring
like he was slamming a guy to an armbar
it was just unbelievable like like he
was like the complete fighter
bj penn was like so flexible he he did
stuff with his body then like nobody
could do his dick the dexterity of his
hips was just unbelievable
um dominic cruz to me was incredible his
footwork his distance control
so when you talk about like the goat
royce gracie another one he did things
that i think for me is not number one
because yeah i gotta i gotta and
starting to interrupt the hoist is a
fascinating one i'd love to hear what
you think about them but
many people
consider you
most people consider you to be the
number one
greatest mixed martial arts fighter
ever
so it's fascinating to remove you from
that list
and continue this discussion and asking
like who do you think is the greatest
fighter ever you listed some amazing
ones hois
you somehow skipped fedor it's as i'm
very as a russian i'm very offended no i
was going to there's so many fedoras one
as well fedor i think in his prime was
like when you say when you talk about a
name for example like
we talked about him when he was in his
prime like when i talked for example
about anderson silva i'm not talking
about the andersons of who fought his
last fight
against urayo hall i'm talking about
anderson servo who knocked out victor
belfor yes
bg pen same thing
the problem is when fighters
hang on for too long in the sport that's
what happened they kind of
make make
people forget how good they were
and it's very sad we talk about fedor
and just just think about uh stephen
yochich
me which is probably the greatest
heavyweight of all time with fedor i
would really wonder who would have won
this fight the both guys in their prime
i tend to lean towards fedor because my
heart was with fever the fedor but he
could have gone the other way but just
because meow chich
lose his last fight now everybody's like
oh yeah they forgot about him
it's crazy man it's one fight you zig
when you shoot zag boom it's
that's the reality of mixed martial art
well that's why the thing is the
mixed martial arts isn't just the
performance the strictly who won and who
lost it's also the stories we tell
ourselves and so
i mean there's beautiful stories being
weaved and that also is part of uh who
is the greatest of all time is
what what were the battles what what
what had to be overcome
what was the
the flavor of the flawless performances
you know all of that
plays into it and you're right being
able to walk away at the top is also
part of that
a lot of people ask me about khabib
and
that fight
i want it to happen
khabib wanted to happen but ufc did not
want to happen between you and khabib
yes and we tried to make it like about
three three years ago when i when i
retired two you know three no it was
after two years ago
and it didn't never came to fruition the
ufc were clear they said they would they
have their plan for khabib and it makes
sense to for the business standpoint
because they want to keep the ball
rolling
now can be retired and like everybody
else after just justin gaitrey i was
doing the comment theater in french for
the ufc and i have butterfly i thought
he was going to call me out
if there's one guy that i would have
said yes it would be him because for a
fighter the most exciting thing things
to do it's often the scariest one
and khabib was
you know where is the scariest matchup
yes
but it was worth the risk because nobody
have ever been able to solve them how
would you solve the khabib nurmagomedov
puzzle well
khabib is very good against the fans
i would have to establish a game plan
and everything but i think
what i would needed to do is take the
center of the octagon right away use a
lot of fake and fate
keep the fight
all the way all the way out or all the
wind and when i sell the win is when you
close the gap use my proactive and
reactive take down and my perhaps my
superior explosivity to put them down
i like to use those proactive and cr and
reactive technology because for me i
feel it's more economical
khabib is a much better chain wrestler
than me chain where stories when he got
the guys to defense it's pure wrestling
what makes my takedown very efficient
it's my karate it's not my wrestling
it's i'm a i'm very good at timing my
opponent and getting in
with with my explosivity so if you watch
at my takedown it does not demand often
it does not demand a lot of work when i
use the i call it proactive takedown
when um
he's coming to punch me and i react so
i mean proactive is when when i i'm
faking it so i i i i instigate the
attack down by a fake then i take take
him down and reactive is when he's i'm
baiting him to throw something and then
he then have a counter yeah yeah yes but
all might take down in the center of the
octagon yes my takedowns are more in the
center of the octagon like for example
another guy that does it well is gleeson
tebow that did it well in his best days
you know
khabib has more a style of chain
wrestling i would say like kamaru uzman
or sort of speak kind of kind of guy
it's a different style you cannot
compare both town
and that's the kind of takedown i'm good
and i would if i would have fight kevin
that's one of the strategies i would
have done i would not have been afraid
because everybody that i thought i was
able to put them down and and
and i have the pedigree to prove it in
my fight resume
so you would have perhaps see him on his
back and i would have perhaps be on my
back as well so it would have been a
very interesting fight and how hard do
you think he is to take down i mean
a lot of people speak about his
wrestling being just it has nothing to
do with it like the wrestling because
let's do the correct if i get that
timing and i got my boat hand around
around his knees he's going down
everybody goes down yeah yes yes this
goes down and and and i had a lot of uh
that's what i would have done i would
not have been afraid of his wrestling uh
i would have be the instigator i would
have forced the fight forward and that's
what that's how i would have approached
that fight which
i believe most of his opponent
were afraid of his wrestling because
they didn't have the tools that i have
to put him down
i would not have forced the wrestling i
would have in in the clinch i would have
tried to disengage i have many ways to
disengage the clinch
i would have wanted to force the fight
in in that in a in a fighting distance
you know like in in a shoot box distance
not in that in a wrestling distance
is it possible
this fight still happens
i
you're young look great in a suit
well
there's a lot of problems now
and the thing is
now i made peace with it
i
no longer don't wanna fight and i don't
it's not gonna happen ufc was not
interested and i'm bound by contract
with the ufc
and by exclusivity there there's some
people says to me oh how about if
russians are a crazy uh
wealthy russian guy come with money yeah
i i i said i have the i'm gonna be uh
in court with ufc
and and also
i'm older now and when i go home man i'm
like
i don't want to do this you know like
and we're always
i don't want to do this but like for
example i was training with freddie
roach a few days ago and i'm hitting
pads you know
and freddie is looking at me and he's
like hey you have the hitch back i'm
like yeah if dana white would walk in
the room in the in the gym at that
precise moment with a with a ufc
contract i would sign it sign it in the
blink of an eye
but then after i go home i'm like hell
no
my belly is full my my you know i'm
healthy i'm wealthy why would i want to
fight for i made peace with it but the
minute i go back in the gym because i
still get it inside me when i train with
the young guys i still get it and a lot
of guys think hey
tell me the truth you're preparing a
comeback because i still get it you know
i'm a little bit older but i i get more
knowledge i can compensate
i i i become a different animal because
you know it changed you
but then after you go home and you
you you're like man uh no way i'm doing
this
yeah it's very hard to explain you need
to be acquired one to understand that
it's very very hard to explain
well from your perspective i think
khabib
is one of the rare one of the few
fascinating scientific puzzles yet to be
solved so from that aspect as a martial
artist
it's just a fascinating journey to try
to solve that puzzle there is a thing
too like say oh who's the best part of
our people
lex they don't like i unders i i
realized that
later in my life and i'm sure a lot of
young guys will say oh i said it's not
don't speak for me but i'm telling you
right now what i'm about to say you will
realize it later
when i was young i think you can
proclaim yourself the
more the badass man on the planet you
know like nobody can beat you at
it's an illusion man that's the sad
thing about for example dc
uh
daniel cormier does probably one of the
greatest if not the greatest of
all time you said miyotis but like
it's almost because of that little
matchup with jon jones it's it's
difficult for people to conceive of him
as the greatest of all time it's all
about matchup it's all about timing and
also you make a fight
you make both guys fight 10 times
the result might be different
like
like every time you know
i mean maybe he's gonna win eight out of
ten
but that knight is gonna he's gonna lose
why because we don't know the the
universe made it like that you know
maybe he got sick maybe he had the
emotional issues he didn't sleep well
and
he makes him uh lose focus and he got
caught
you don't we don't know but it's it's
that's the thing with people ask me
would you have done it with khabib what
would happen i don't know maybe out of
10 time i don't know maybe as a fighter
i hope i would have win
more than him he thinks the opposite is
only one way to find out but
that night if there's a fight
the guy gonna win doesn't mean he's the
best fighter that's mean
the
the he's the one that fought the best
the night of the fight same thing in
basketball or aki the team that wins the
game it's not necessarily the best team
is the team
that play the best the the night of the
game and fighting is no different so
being the baddest man on the planet it's
an illusion
i mean that's the tragic thing about it
is uh on any one night
anything can happen and then that tells
a story for all of human history it is
it's
uh
it's that it's sad to think about but
that's what makes it beautiful that
there's so much at stake like entire
lives all the dreams you've had growing
up all the hard work all of it is
decided in a single night even though
that means nothing in terms of who's
actually better it's uh i mean that's
the beauty that's why people love the
olympics especially because it happens
so rarely
and dreams are broken
or uh like triumph is achieved by the
unlikely hero all like
right there
i mean that's that's why we love it
right that's why
that's why i love it if we would know
always the result before it would be
boring that's why we do it you know
uh you watch the odds you know like like
sometimes i like to watch the odds uh
before a fight you know
because
you know
there's things you know i believe in
causality you know i believe in
everybody believe different things but i
believe everything is because there's a
there's a cause to everything that's
personally what i believe
i don't believe that
i i have like free will i think i have
the illusion of free will but i believe
there's a cause for everything and if
i'm doing something because of something
because of a cause by definition there's
no free will in a way you know if
there's a cause by definition
there's not how does that make you feel
by the way like the idea that if we just
look
uh outside of even just human psychology
and fighting and so on if we look at
like physics if everything is
predetermined if all of these little
molecules interacting
it's already like your story is already
written i mean it depends it's it's
written but i would need to know all the
data and it's impossible right like it's
it's
i it's kind of weird i gotta say but i
don't
to me
i don't see any argument
to counter that idea i i i i can i don't
maybe i'm i'm ignorant but i haven't
seen nobody and everything from that
i've read so far there's nothing that
countered that idea that that
because in a mechanical world
if your car broke or
you know we don't say oh the car decided
to broke or a three a tree is fall
there's reason why the tree is falling
we don't say the trees decide to fall
right so because us human being i think
it's our ego we decide and i'm no
different than anybody when i make a
decision i decided to do this i choose
to do this
but i'm aware that
there is causes
that make me do certain things
and by definition i think if there is a
cause
there is no free will by definition
right
yes but the thing is just like you said
we understand so little about human
intelligence the human mind and
especially consciousness
that
the
this giant
mystery this darkness that we don't
understand how how it
how it feels like to be something to be
a conscious being
that
because of that we're not able to really
even reason about free will or not
because there might be some magic
that comes from consciousness the you
know the the consciousness might be the
thing that makes us different from a car
that breaks down
there might be something
uh totally
fascinating totally
undiscovered yet that will make us
realize that free will is actually real
and somehow fundamental to the human
experience so
it's sometimes i think
we forget when we talk about
free will and
physics and it all seeming to be
predetermined
we forget how little we actually
understand about the world
and i think
in that mystery that could be
totally new ideas that are yet to be
discovered and will make us realize that
it's not just an illusion
it is something that is like
at the core of how the universe works
some people believe that consciousness
is a
fundamental property of the universe
like it's a it's a one of the forces of
physics like consciousness permeates
everything it's in everything like this
table is conscious but it's not
as conscious as us and we're this little
peak of consciousness and if that's true
and if we get to understand that maybe
there's something
there's an extra bonus we get in terms
of free will
once you become one of those entities
that are super conscious
so
i i tend to be sort of humbled by the
mystery of it
do you believe
one day with
with the technology that keep improving
we will
make
a
robot that will be able to
be somehow conscious
absolutely i that's been my dream that's
been i hope i hope to do just that
first of all i believe that
all people are capable and want to be
good to each other
and
i think love is uh is a really powerful
thing that connects us and can create
better and better worlds sort of like
uh
create better and better societies that
improve both the technology the quality
of life and just the basics of human
experience and i think
creating ai systems that are conscious
that are human-like
can enable us to
be better to each other like they can
it's almost like adding more and more
kindness to the world through the
systems we interact with will inspire us
to be better and better to each other
in terms of them being conscious i think
that is a an absolute requirement
that entities we interact with
communicate some element
of consciousness to us like that's how
we connect to each other the reason we
you and i connect is that we believe
that each of us are conscious
and to me what consciousness means is
the ability to hurt ability to
to suffer
to uh to struggle in this world
because just like you said uh
with with without the struggle you don't
have the love you don't have the
pleasure
and
ultimately consciousness is an entity's
ability
to struggle to suffer
and
from that arises the pleasure and us
together being able to
appreciate sort of uh
appreciate the highs
and
experience together at the lows that's
how we form the deep connections
i personally think we can create that in
robots and i i personally believe it's a
lot easier than uh than we think does it
make you afraid sometimes
about
the fact that
one day hey hi like intelligence
artificial intelligence could be
you know could hurt us or or you know
like because we're you know because of
hollywood of course you know the movies
we watch but but it seems like when i
hear sometimes elon musk talking you
know like
yeah so
elon talks about with ai we're summoning
the demon
he is very concerned and i talked to him
about it quite a bit he's very concerned
about all the different ways ai could
hurt us humans
i tend to believe that there's a lot
more ways in which ai can make our lives
better and
can make life awesome for humans i think
humans
are the ones that can do a lot of evil
things
so i'm less worried about i am more
worried about humans
if i look at what you men have done on
on the course of history
you know for for example
in regards to the planet to the the
scale of the universe
i think
what i'm afraid is that we have more
of a
destructive force than a beneficial
force so if a height take that and cause
the duration in order to
protect us against ourselves
it could
hurt us in a way i don't know if you if
you understand what like
what do you think about that does it
makes you afraid sometimes not because
of a hype but because of what humans are
doing
that heihei could do to us to prevent us
of hurting
ourselves you know yeah no i mean
definitely it can bring out the the
worst in human nature and uh
provide tools for evil people to do evil
things at a larger scale but i just
think
it depends what you think human beings
are i tend to believe
that as we get more intelligent
we
we start to see the value
the evolutionary value and the value in
terms of happiness of being good to each
other and i think ai if if you look at
ai as an optimization problem of how to
create a civilization that works well
and expands throughout the universe
i think love
is much uh more effective so ai will
help us
maximize that
i think there's going to be always
spikes throughout as it has been through
human history where charismatic leaders
will do evil onto the world in the name
of good you have the stalin and the
hitlers and all of that
but
ultimately
over time i think technology will give
the good
uh the good people power and the evil
people
less power
now there's a lot of ways in that in uh
that that won't be the case there's a
lot of ways for it to go wrong and elon
talks about them but
i i honestly think in terms of
intelligent ai that's going to bring
more love to the world the thing i'm
concerned about is dumb ai
so there's been a lot of discussion
between china and the united states
recently on autonomous weapons system
this is something people don't
they're afraid to talk about but
there's now a race
uh where
the united states has officially said
that they're not against adding ai to
its weapon systems so now
the us military
is adding automation
adding intelligence
to its drones
to its uh
anything that can create damage
and so of course and they did this so in
response to china doing that
so you can imagine this is this is
terminator
you think about terminators intel
intelligent systems they're not they're
pretty dumb
the the point is
they're efficient at doing what they do
and in the space of war
efficient at doing what you do means
killing
so
that i'm really afraid of but those are
dumb ai those aren't your
uh
loving
deep
fulfilling relationships that's like
uh efficiently being able to fly to plan
the trajectory of dropping bombs of
missiles of how to do counter attacks of
how to maximize the destruction of a
particular facility instead of
individuals
and then
that can just escalate
and as opposed to the cold war with the
with the soviet union this could be a
hot war
and then
the consequences
once you allow
it's kind of terrifying because
currently the drones are operated by
humans so
you know you have say you have
information
about uh intelligence gives you
information about a particular terrorist
located at this area
and then
you use drones to
maybe uh
the automation there is to help you
figure out what is the best trajectory
to
strike at that location so
you still have a human that pulls the
trigger at the end
dropping the bomb now automation and ai
in autonomous weapons systems
might be where you say
there's a bad guy over here
you figure out how to get rid of the bad
guy okay so then of course the systems
will be very good at finding the right
trajectory and so on
but
there's bugs that can happen unexpected
bugs that the system might figure out
that there is
this bad guy might actually be in these
other
five locations so mike's might make
sense to cover the entire area right
and you see you might just drop bombs on
the entire area and then
you know that's just okay so that's
going to lead to a lot of destruction of
the scale of a city but then you can
immediately take that to nuclear weapons
if you add automation to uh responding
to counterattacks to nuclear weapons
somebody you might get information that
somebody's planning a nuclear attack on
the united states and the ai system will
immediately respond
and you know it can respond at a scale
of launching nuclear weapons itself and
so there's all of these possibilities
that don't require much intelligence and
that's exceptionally that's
exceptionally concerning i i'm like you
i do not believe there is
babies that are born bad i think people
do bad things because of their
experience
however
if i look
to my experience and from what i can see
some very often
men's of power
wants more power
that's what makes me afraid with yeah no
absolutely i
listen i've been uh i've come from the
soviet union
uh stalin is arguably one of the most
powerful humans in history uh he's not
talked often enough about by the evils
he's done hitler gets all the attention
yeah but stalin has done arguably much
more evil than uh than hitler yeah well
this is this is human nature it wants
power
we see that with institutions we see
that with governments and nations
i think
you see you see this with the internet
people are really hungry
for the distribution of power
like you see that people are very much
distrustful of centralized places of
power of institutions and so on so i
think successful organizations
successful companies
successful governments
will be run by people who distribute the
power
like i don't trust myself with power at
all yeah and i think you have to
build into the system
that no one person can have power
and that you distribute it that's where
you have in the financial sector you
have cryptocurrency right now with
bitcoin and all those kinds of things
people are exploring how can we avoid
the central bank
to have the control how do you put the
power in the hands of people uh
thousands of people millions of people
and in the same way with uh with
military with um any kind of
uh with technology
i think the future looks very
distributed so what do you think about
militarizing space
[Laughter]
the uh space force i i i don't think
about it often because right now i'm
filled with excitement about space
exploration which is the positive aspect
so elon
you know i was born
in an era where it was exciting i don't
know about you but for me it's exciting
to look up to the stars and
dream about us humans ex you know uh
colonizing mars colonizing other planets
expanding onto the galaxy into the
universe that's really exciting
uh so
i'm um
the the the possibilities there are
endless i don't think
because the also the resources are
endless
and so i think we get into trouble with
militarization with wars when the
resources are very constrained
so i think for a while we're not going
to be fighting
the the only wars we'll be fighting in
space are the ones that kind of um
another nation to compete yeah who goes
to the moon first i guess that's those
those are kind of those kinds of things
or maybe for satellites and all those
kinds of communication and uh maybe in
assistance for like cyber warfare which
is also very dangerous but in terms of
space
wars out in space i think
i think everything out in space will be
positive and inspiring it's very hard
but
all good things are hard i think
this is where i've been i've been
talking to a bunch of people about um
extraterrestrial life
i'm really excited by
i don't know it's the other thing um
when i look out to the stars it's
exciting to me i know i think you've
spoken about it being scary
but to me it's exciting that there's
intelligent creatures out there
far beyond perhaps the intelligence of
our own
that uh are just too far away to explore
yet but we might one day come in contact
with them
so uh that that to me is the ultimate
motivator is to meet other intelligence
life forms out there and connect with
them
have you ever meet jacques valley
no but i've been in communication i want
to i hope to talk to him he's amazing
french yeah i am
i know that there are many theories
about yes
you know if there is alien we don't know
right but but some people think it's
from another star systems
and jaguar is a like to make a long
story short he has a different theory he
thinks it's perhaps
beans that
could be living in a different dimension
than us and the reason why he says that
is
when he makes an experiment when there
is a signings very often of a ufo
let's say i'm i'm the ufo that you have
three guys
and one they they are looking at the ufo
very often
one experiment that
you can do and sometimes that that is
the case you asked your two friend to
walk on the side and there's a at a
point that it's like a corridor you see
the ufo and then you stop seeing like a
corridor and
that's one of the reason why he's saying
that
it's perhaps a dimension and i found
that fascinating you know i
this is what you know to the discussion
of consciousness and all that it it
feels like we might be just experiencing
a very particular slice of this universe
we might not be understanding what's at
the higher dimensions or
yeah i mean higher dimensions in
whatever form that means you know
there's all these physical theories now
that describe a world with dimensions
that's much higher than the four
dimensions of the three-dimensional
space in one dimension of time
so
whatever the hell is going on in those
other dimensions it could be
something
unfortunately this is the sad part it
might be something we can't even
comprehend with our human brains
that the limitations are just um
i mean we're built we're just
descendants of apes so like it might not
be possible to even understand is there
alien is there another dimension are
they a human from the future is there
perhaps chinese or another
you know what i mean a group of people
that are working with a technology far
behind but you know what lex i had a
chance to meet you know because of the
sport i'm doing
i met a lot of
people in military and politics
sometimes that i i asked them every time
i met i met one this week and and um
i i i asked him i say is it true about
the the uf who is there is there and he
says to me is like
before even before i ask him i say
sorry i have to ask you a question
i wasn't in los angeles
sorry i have to ask you questions oh you
want to ask me about ufo right away you
knew i said yes you saw it in your eyes
say yeah there is things that flies that
we don't know but it does it didn't tell
me he doesn't know it they don't know if
it's you know whatever but there's
things apparently that
are detected and i know you met uh
forever you know like flavors
fascinating
crazy it makes me sad that we live in a
different area now that that it's used
to be a
subject that was ridiculed and now it's
so cool that it's you know i'm very
excited to live in to that that era you
know yeah it's really exciting but still
the governments are kind of behind the
times on that aspect is
they're not transparent and they don't
communicate well
you know it saddens me to think the
possibility that that
you know like the us government might be
in possession of something that they
don't tell the world about because
they're just scared
it's because they don't know what the
hell it is and they don't want the
chinese to gain the technology or all
those kinds of things
do you think the president of the united
states for example because the president
comes and go every right four or eight
years do you think he would know all the
secret or
it would be a guy like for example
vladimir putin with no
much of a you know
i don't think the president even know
like even can he knows all all the the
secrets the u.s president yeah i don't
think so because he goes they go back
and forth you know every four years you
know they have the terms right
so i you know i i wasn't sure before but
i think i could trust the previous
united states president of donald trump
that if he knew
he would probably tweet about it so
perhaps
so
i yeah i i think
from from the con you know i've worked
with darpa i work with uh dod at
clearance and
i think from the perspective
if you if you see the world as
fundamentally a dangerous world
where
secrets are important to have from a
military perspective
i think it's very unsafe to tell
the president in the united states
that you have this kind of technology so
if you think of the world in that way i
i hate that that's how that world is
viewed because ultimately i think what's
more powerful than the military secrets
and i hope that actually is what will
happen in the 21st century
because what's more powerful
is inspire people
inspire the the young elon musks of the
world
to to create cool new things if we have
technology that we've
come have encountered that we don't
understand that should only be
inspiration
to uh develop that kind of stuff it
shouldn't be seen as military
as a military threat as a secret to hold
on to
i think secrets um
i hope
we more and more let go of the idea that
there are secrets that give us advantage
you know like in the tech sector people
are more and more releasing the software
they're making an open source
like secrets don't make sense
they share the knowledge right share the
share the knowledge like share like
being afraid to share the knowledge i
think i hope is an old idea it's more
yeah when you make it things more
compartmentalized you know yes
well yeah what that's the other thing is
the bureaucracy of government is like
people only know their own little thing
and they don't spread the information it
doesn't travel well i mean there's a lot
of just inefficiencies that are it makes
me sad it makes me sad because uh
the
the science the engineering that happens
in governments like lockheed martin
developing the different
airplanes that they use for military
applications is some of the most
incredible engineering ever and it's
secret because they're afraid to share
it with the russians and the chinese and
so on
but on that topic i do think somebody
like vladimir putin window probably
knows some stuff
my god my god i would i would love to
know what he knows but then again you
never know because even he is you know
people think of him as an exceptionally
powerful person
but he's also just managing a bunch of
tribes
his power is very limited he's trying to
hold together
uh a bunch of greedy
power-hungry
mad men that's right okay and he's
trying to establish a balance
he might not know everything so
i i hope this changes because i think
there's nothing more exciting about
i don't even know if there is a human
that knows you know what i mean like
this idea that
there's some civilization alien
civilization that that land on the white
house and say hi i come to meet the
prison and like
why would they do that you know what i
mean
it's kind of absurd you know well i i do
think that actually i mean that's one
possibility right is lart
you know if an alien civilization really
wanted to contact us i think everybody
would know
so i think what we're
if if there's any kind of interaction
between humans
and aliens i think most likely what
we're interacting with is the crappy
like probe drone thing
that kind of just like like it's like
this
yeah
yeah
this dumb thing you know we're not
interacting with the aliens i think just
like
just like for us
i think humans aren't when we uh venture
out into space
the first thing that's going to mean
aliens is our robots it's not us humans
because we keep sending robots out so
they're going to like
they're going to make decisions about
humans by looking at the robots
i say their famous greys
the greys maybe they're our robots maybe
it's all bs2 you know yeah yeah so i i
don't know
i don't know what uh that interaction
actually would look like if aliens
really wanted to reach out really
communicate and i don't know if we're
able to actually communicate with them
that's one of the sad things we might
not be able to
that we might the aliens might already
be here and we might just not even
know
know how to see them or know how to
communicate with them
there's so much
misinformation and sometimes there is
people
that are very credible that that
that made crazy claims you know like
like you don't know what to believe you
know like paul ellior the the
the
minister of defense of canada i've said
like some
that there is many alien race that ever
that that's what he says research it and
then
did that that scientists
from i think israel recently have said
something about trump he was keeping
secret or medvedev you're from russia
they have been caught in there like
during a break
in between interviews to talks about
like oh it's like men in blacks over to
speak i don't know he didn't look like
he was joking but
i don't know if he didn't know about
this yeah you can check on youtube it'd
say it's it's it's it went viral yeah
there's a lot of things like that
sometime like
or or bob lazar i'm like
imagine if it's true man yeah
you might imagine if we if we're like a
fish in the water we live in our own
world and sometimes there's a
fisherman that grabbed the fish yeah
take him out of the water and threw it
back in the water and the fish goes back
to the other fish and say
hey
there's someone that that take me out of
the water then i've seen uh things that
i did not like imagine if it's true like
we like
yeah and and one other thing like
i wanted to ask you because you were
consciousness how about dreams what is a
dream yeah well i i more and more i
don't know if you're paying attention to
this there's now it's become more
acceptable in the scientific community
to do large-scale studies of
psychedelics for example and there's a
lot of connection between psychedelics
and dreams it's very similar states
there's
there's a lot our mind does
when it detaches itself from reality
that it can just explore a lot of
different ideas it's very possible that
dreams is you're traveling somewhere and
the same thing with psychedelics you're
traveling somewhere
in a different
not traveling through physical space
it's the other dimensions that we're
talking about you're traveling some
other
through some other dimension to meet
some other creature people talk with dmt
that they meet some elves i've never
done i i'd like to i don't know if
there's a safe legal way to do it but uh
they all talk about meeting elves
and they're like creatures like entities
and like who are who are they
what's
what is this is it because they're high
or it's because
they're actually meeting something and
maybe there's no difference i mean that
uh who knows exactly and that takes us
right back to us not being able to
really understand how our mind works
you know i work in artificial
intelligence
it's clear that we understand so little
about intelligence some basic things
about intelligence
just at the at the very sort of basic uh
first principles level we don't
understand what it means
to to reason
to think
to assimilate pieces of knowledge
together
from the from the basics to the complex
we don't understand it we don't
understand how the human mind does it
we don't understand how the human mind
is able to take incredible waterfall of
information and filter cleanly into just
like
clean you only see the things that are
important and are able to jump together
and be able to reason about the world
and at the same time have moments of
like genius of creativity like what what
is that that also you know people
writers talk about that that they're you
know they're almost like communicating
with the muse like where do ideas come
from yeah this is the joe rogan
philosophy but but i i do know that past
civilization were a lot of them were
based on shamanism
and you know what i think it's sad is
if someone
drink alcohol
and when he's drunk he's going to commit
like
create like like murders or something
we're going to blame the person right
we're going to say that's his fault it's
not the fault of alcohol however if
someone does psychedelic or any things
that is illegal and do something crazy
now we're gonna
put the fault on on psychedelic you know
what i mean and perhaps the person
itself is the
the reason why you know he's been doing
these things you know what i mean
so
yeah it's fascinating how like society
you know like in canada they just
legalized marijuana
oh yeah
but before that before they did it like
if you talk for example to my dad my dad
is against it like because the whole
mentality is like it's drug it's bad at
that but drinking a glass you know
drinking a beer it's fine i mean
what is you know what i mean what is
good what is bad and
i guess you think chocolate could be bad
as well for your health or i mean i'm
going to the extreme now but yeah what
is good what is bad if you use it for
recreation you use it for an experience
for to learn about yourself
it's like it it said that the line is
very
tiny you know there are some countries
that
drugs are all legals you know what i
mean and i i don't know the the the
stats but i would i would be interesting
to know if
they have more
crimes there than
other countries where it's more strict i
would that would be interesting to know
about that it's fascinate me you know
yeah and i mean we humans kind of just
come up with the arbitrary lines of
what's good what's bad that applies with
drugs that applies with anything uh that
applies with animals for example we
talked about carnivore diet
maybe the time we live and now will be
remembered for
the cruelty to animals for example
and i believe
this the 21st century will be remembered
for our cruelty to robots
that uh eventually
there will be a civil rights movement
for robots where the the ones who uh
choose to be conscious the ones who have
consciousness will say we deserve rights
too
we deserve to be treated with respect
too
how about the people we put in jail
people put in jail i mean if i think in
the future we'll look back
and we'll
think of ourselves being stupid to
you know to put people in jail instead
of you know like
trying to fix the problem in in in
at the base you know of course now we're
or i guess it's our endurance that made
it in a way that we cannot sort
sometimes understand what makes uh
sometimes a psychopath a psychopath or a
murder or murderer but
you know if we can pinpoint the problem
and take care of it before you know what
i mean
or made it in the way that we can
reestablish that person in the society
you know who knows you know what was
their future is old it's interesting we
live in an interesting time
you mentioned your father
what have you learned from your dad you
mentioned he was an important part of
your childhood my dad is amazing
i grew up we didn't have a lot of money
but it doesn't mean if i'm born in a
nice country that always nice thing
happen you know
my dad for me is a big role model
because i see him through
to my life facing a lot of adversity you
know he um
he stopped drinking when i was a
teenager he was an alcoholic
and i seen him struggle through that you
know and it was very very hard and um
i've seen him
work
like crazy hours
like come leave in the morning come home
at night burned out because of work
through almost all his life
to the point that it became
a slave of the system yes
it became a habit and a normal way of
living
and it made me realize that i've learned
a lot through my father
he taught me perseverance hard work you
know
when you face adversity you know to
never give up until you achieve it
but also he
it taught me a lesson that
in a way that i don't want to be like
him even if he is happy
it's because i realize i don't think he
knows anything else like he works
through all his life
and
i don't want to live to work i want to
work for it for you know what i mean i
want to decide when i work you know i
feel like like he
he lived to work instead of working for
a living
and
perhaps it's because he did not have
choice
he he was the older of his family they
had they were nine kid his dad
my grandfather died when he was young so
he had to become the father of the
family and and work to put money on the
table
so perhaps that what
made him that way and he became like
like a habit for him
my dad taught me uh when i was at school
i was bullied at school
he's the first one to initiate me to a
martial art he taught me kyrati my dad
my dad was a black belt in kyokushin
karate as well very nice but because he
was working too much he didn't have time
to teach me and i needed self defense in
order to defend myself
i have a winning a great carrier and
mixed martial art but in the in the
schoolyard
that's so good my mixed record
my my record is not very good
when you're a kid
and you're about
seven eight years old and you're facing
bullied
bullies that are
two to three years older than than
yourself
it's not the same thing than when you're
25 and the guy is 28 so there is a big
discrepancy in terms of maturity
so
my dad taught me introduced me to karate
danny i didn't he didn't have time to
teach me then he put me
in a school
with an a teacher that said it was jean
kutzer
and i grew up with a lot of anger
and uh there were two
person that was afraid growing up
it was my dad my dad was very severe
very strict with me
and i'm glad he was because i i could
have become very bad i could have become
chosen on a different path people see me
as a nice guy and i'm gonna i am a nice
guy i try to be a good role model
but i could easily have turned towards
our around there's darkness somewhere in
there yes they are a lot and a lot of my
friends have chosen that pat and
unfortunately
you know they they are they are
they are not with me today
even if i'm from canada and canada seems
like the nicest country in the world
like i said it's even if you live in a
nice country not always nice thing it
depend of the situation
but that's what my dad taught me you
know and he gave me that
to
to
because i i'm very good at learning by
observing people and by observing him i
i see the the struggle he had with
alcoholism and what he did the the the
pain sometimes that even flick
to to to us to my family but
how he
turned
he did that 180 degree
and
i really admire that and i know it was
uh very very hard for him and he did it
you know and uh for me uh that's a great
role model for me
so with your dad being an engine of
basically hard work and you finding a
balance of being able to work your ass
off
but also to be able to enjoy a piece of
chocolate
what is the perfect day
in the life of georgetown pierre look
like
so like
if you were to go through a day that's
very productive but also want to
make you sit back and enjoy and say that
was a good day what's that look like
what are we talking about when do you
wake up what do you eat
what do you do it changed over the years
when i was younger i have a good day it
was like a good training session or you
know achieving good thing in my training
you know and that's why i was very good
at it because
when i i was obsessed you know i think
to be good at something you need to
become obsessed and to me
performing in my training was everything
you know like
when i had a bad training session
i didn't tell my training partner i was
acting like a like because of the my ego
i didn't you know i didn't tell nobody i
was like hey then i go in the locker
room i'm like
man
then then i'm playing the the the
the training in my mind you know i'm
saying okay i should have done this
shouldn't have done and it hunt me
it hunt me man it's a training and it
hunt me
until the next running session on when i
can redeem myself
that's how it is
when we used to train in
all together back in a day
in canada we had
david luizo we had patrick
we had uh dennis kang
uh steven
jonathan there was all like the best guy
in canada that were training with each
other before we were training in
different gyms but once a week
i made it in a way that i contact
everybody that we all join for us and we
exchange ideas and we train with each
other so a friendly i would say friendly
competition it was not
malicious but it was hard training you
know like not our goal is was to improve
you know but it wasn't
very competitive
and when
that day you used to get out of the
training session with a bad performance
for me
he used to hunt me until the following
week when i could give it back and and
perform better with the guy that i had
the most trouble with
that's how it was and that's how you get
better you know but but
it was not a training where it it it
would we were trying to do malicious
thing to one another you know what i
mean
you need to be playful but playful but
competitive
that when i had a good training session
because aspiring was on a friday
i had the best weekend and what i was
going out with my friend drinking and
partying and have fun that was
that was my my my my ideal day back in
the day
today is strange you know my my my life
has changed you know like um
i
i am not the same person i used to be
when i go went on my knees and begged
the ufc for a title shot you know what i
mean i i am uh
i'm wealthy
i'm healthy most importantly that's the
most important thing
and
as man i'm gonna tell you the truth as
good as my career was
man my private life man is a million
times better man
i i and and people ask me sometime they
always wonder they they try to ask me
and it's normal it's a lot of people is
curious and they're the reporter
and
in the sport
of mixed martial art we say we play
basketball we play soccer but you don't
play fighting
so when you expose your private life
we've seen that happen in the fight week
sometime conor mcgregor and khabib
your competitor
knows that he cannot get to use what he
will do he will try to get to someone
that you love
so may i never expose my my private life
i never post instagram of my family of
my stuff
that's the reason why because i mean
i'm in a business of fighting
and people know that they cannot get to
me
and i believe
because i was bullied when i was young
i didn't realize that when i was young
but it helps me deal with the mental
warfare that i need that i had to face
later on in my life in mixed martial art
because it's a very egotistic sport and
there's a lot of
a lot and a lot of
intimidation and i was used to i've been
used to this thing when i was young so
it does not get to me
however the good way to get to me
go go go go try to get to someone i i
love now man
i'm gonna go crazy you know what i mean
and i'm aware of that so in order to
protect myself
i always because i'm aware i'm a public
person
so i try to always keep my surrounding
like in a private
yeah one of the ways that like uh your
your friend of mine joe rogan has
been an inspiration that he he's got
like an incredible family and he for the
most part is starting to change recently
actually it's kind of interesting but
for the most part throughout his life he
kept it pretty secret
doesn't talk about it and he's calm he's
a comedian comedians talk about
everything he doesn't really talk about
it
and there's something to that it like
preserves the magic of this the silence
of the private life and i think it can
affect the
the development of the kid
if the kid grew up being oh he's the son
of
that guy instead of being his own person
you know what i mean
so so for me it's very important
like my parents are older it's fine
but it taught me a big lesson
when i'm with my friend at the dinner or
anything i talk with person always share
a thing but when i'm talking i'm aware
of of the audience who i'm in front
yeah and i mean but oftentimes those
people are just incredible it kind of
makes me sad
that uh
you know there's a lot of people that
love you right and they're a lot of
really incredible people and you'll
never get to really know their story
that's right i mean i don't know for me
it makes me sad you see them like at
airports and stuff people will tell me
they listen to this podcast or something
like that
and they're i could tell they're
incredible people and it makes me it's
like a little goodbye
of a possible friend i don't know it
makes me sad it's right it makes me
it's lonely it's almost like celebrity
is a lonely thing so the higher the
celebrity the more lonely you become
in some kind of way but of course you
have that little gem of a private life
where you can personally i believe every
relationship i i
like i don't like to use this term but
it's always a give and take relationship
you know
like you can gain something and the
person like it it could be something
like not material is materialistic like
something always a good confident like
you're someone that they can give me
good advice or or
it's a word i would say like extensional
like if a pilot as a co-pilot is the
co-pilot is extend as a extensional
relationship with him you know so he
knows if he gets sick or he faint he's
there to make sure you know he is there
to help
and i think in every relation
it's about compatibility but it's about
extensionality right in a way that if
that person is extensional
and sometimes we talk about about love
you know like
sometimes i think is is it is it a bs
word or not because i myself sometimes
look at
i look at myself in the mirror
and when i do s
stupid thing
sometimes i love myself a lot and
sometimes i don't you know what i mean
because i'm angry at myself i've done
stupid thing
so that means sometimes you could love
could be fluctuating you know what i
mean
how about in relationships sometimes you
people they say oh they love each other
but then when they divorce they go oh i
want the house and the dog and the kids
stay with me and you know what i mean
if you love if by definition if you
really love someone
and let's say you're an old man and you
love a woman and she decided to leave
you for a younger man if you really love
her
you're gonna help her pack and leave but
in our society sometimes we we want to
hone something to me love includes
the missing somebody
losing somebody the anger at somebody
it's all the passion feelings towards
somebody that's all love okay i you know
it's all part of the thing it's the ups
and downs
it's uh
the sad thing is when the feelings
towards the person the ups and downs go
away they're forgetting
yeah that's that's the opposite of love
so the opposite of love isn't hate the
to me the opposite of love is forgetting
and and that's that's a much bigger
that's like the depth of human
connection that's how i see love so
sometimes i try to stay positive and
i've been asked
how i try to because i have the image of
someone who's positive but i go to my
own demon as well sometime
however
we talk about love
when i was young
you know like
like i didn't love
who i was at first that's how i love i
learned to kind of love myself
like i didn't and then when i was going
to to bullying i was i believe i was
bullied because i didn't love myself i i
because i project a very bad image
of what i think of myself i was a kid
that lacked a lot of confidence i was
looking down when i was walking i
shrugged my shoulder
when someone was talking to me i was
avoiding eye contact
so i was a very easy target for the
bullies and
i think bullies are like in predatory
animal in nature they will hunt the the
easier prey they would don't they don't
go the lion don't go
for the the alpha bull they go for the
one who's old or who's sick the weakest
one and bullies are the same in society
i believe
and i didn't like
to be bullied of course but i didn't
like the the person that i was
but i found out through martial art
the respect
and
my my coach was extraordinary to me he
taught me discipline and self strength
self strength and i found out that i
needed to in order to love myself i
needed to change myself
because i didn't when i looked at my son
in the mirror i didn't like what i saw
so i decided to become
like someone that i would love
so
i tried to
look people straight up
and and trying to
showcase
a more confident image
that i had and it was hard in the
beginning because i didn't really
believe in it but i
i faked it
until kind of i make it so when i was
walking
at school
more and more i was learning how to
become more confident and i was like
taking charge when the teacher was
asking questions i was at first i was
never answering i was like this waiting
always to be the last then i was hey i i
i know what the answer this is the
answer i got out
of my
comfort zone so to speak
and i wish i would tell you that i got
out of bullying
because a hollywood story i use martial
art to beat up all the bullies but it's
not how it happened to me it happened
because i changed myself from the inside
out
and
i learned how to
because i didn't love myself in the
beginning
i learned
how to become
like someone that i love and even now
like i'm by no mean perfect i do a lot
of stupid thing
but i learn
as a person and even i do have something
stupid i'm like shoot i did something
stupid i
at least i can apologize to the person
if i realize and then
i know that i'm not the person i was in
the past
i'm the person
that i am right now so i can learn
and become that image of the person that
i love so in in a way
the reason i'm trying to be positive and
i and i am able to stay positive
sometime in life
is because i'm always trying
to be like that person that i love yeah
and i think if you don't look yourself
in the mirror and don't love yourself or
don't see any positive future for
yourself
how can you change your environment if
you cannot change yourself you know what
i mean you would never be happy if
you're not happy when you look at
yourself in the mirror
so change yourself first then change
your you know it's not the environment
you're gonna change for yourself it's
you have to go from the inside out you
know
this this i learned to martial art i
have a i had a coach who was incredible
used to drill these ideas in my head and
and give me confidence you know like
like this telling me all these these
beautiful
things about myself and how i
he's dead now unfortunately peace peace
to him but uh he was incredible
incredible he was very very strict i was
afraid of him i was afraid of my dad and
afraid of him he couldn't teach nowadays
like he used to teach me because he
would be in probably in jail you know
but i'm glad he did it because for that
time being that's what i needed it
and i would never have had that the
career i had in mixed martial art
without this
because i would i would never have got
out of my
comfort zone would have been impossible
and in order to improve in life
you need to get out of your comfort zone
it's hard it's very hard to do
and and strive to be the person that you
can love i i does that's that's
beautifully put george if you were to
give advice to a young person today
about life what would you tell him
if he
takes
life
with the same
mentality that i do
if he has the same
taste of things that i have
i would tell him
you know for for for sport for life in
general i would say
if you will have a dream
you know like
make everything in your power and work
very hard you know never take no for an
answer
and go through hell in order to achieve
it
don't work
hard only but work smart
that's i think the problems with a lot
of people they work hard they can work
hard they burn themselves they don't
work smart
whether it is in
in science and business they make
bad choices or they are badly informed
in sport
how many guys i've seen ruin their
career in the gyms
they they spar so hard they they ruined
themself in the gyms they leave their
career in the gyms
what i would say to for example because
my field of expertise and it's in sport
of mixed martial art
i would say to
you young
kid
make your training playful
you know when you get ready for
for competition you need to trying to
recreate those
elements that makes you
go outside of your comfort zone
but in every days life in general make
your training playful
don't makes it like a hardcore
competition about who's who's winning
who's losing make make it playful so
it will increase
because
your
know you will not be afraid of
getting hurt
or losing
you will be tent
to trying more things
and be you it will make you become more
create creative
you know
that brings up another question about
learning
so you
you value knowledge
and you're exceptional at
basically being very good at learning
and figuring stuff out new things
or going deeper on the things you
already know so what advice would you
have for how to learn
effectively how you know you say work
smart
how do you
figure this game out i believe the best
way to learn
is learning from other people's mistake
[Laughter]
however
i'm not perfect and i've learned from my
mistakes as well and sometimes i've
i it took it took me a few mistakes
to learn the same thing
but
especially in the sport of mixed martial
art because we're talking about
the the failure
could have very serious uh outcome on
someone's life and well-being
so it's crucial
to trying to learn from other people's
mistakes do you study others
do
every every fight
i'm studying my opponent and i've
studied myself as well to know
what
how my strength
mix
versus my opponent weaknesses and how
can i
make the fight
go in a way that i'm taking my opponent
outside of his comfort zone
very often people are good at studying
their opponent but they're not good at
looking at themselves in the mirror and
knowing what they should do in order to
to maximize their
their odds of success right
that's why i always thought
for me
it was important to not be the best at
one thing
but be
very good at everything
that's why i always seek
advice
advices from
the best and every discipline like i
wrestle with the best wrestler i i i
could be with
i box with the best boxers i i
practice karate with the best karate
fighters uh same thing in jiu-jitsu i
trained jiu jitsu with the best best
jiu-jitsu guys
however when i mix
everything and mix martial art
if i if i'm because i'm very confident
in every areas so when i'm fighting
someone
i'm very good at and that the
identifying
where is the less competent
and i know for a fact that because i'm
competent everywhere i can
if i can bring the fight where he's
outside of his comfort zone it increased
my odds of winning there is no certainty
it's all about odds i believe because
there is always x factor that you do not
control yeah it's fascinating to see you
actually because you've been a student
of movement
uh you've been exploring all kinds i
mean gymnastics all that kind of stuff
there there's something reminiscent to
um
like uh conor mcgregor is one other
martial artist that's kind of explored
movement been a scholar of movement
um at least from my perspective it's
very sort of bruce lee like
it's almost making a study of the human
body and all the possible things you can
do is there a philosophy behind that
that you have
you talk about bruce lee man
he changes my my life too
he was ahead of his time
yeah incredible a lot of people talked
to me and asked me hey is brucy would
have been able to fight in ufc i
look i don't think so you know i don't
know
i think he was a you know he was a
martial artist he could have defended
himself but
to say that he could have compete in
amongst the elite of the elite fighter
perhaps in his time but if for sure if
you put him in ufc right now
you know the sport hasn't improved
incredibly since then
but
in terms of philosophy yeah bruce was
amazing like one thing that just to
prove that he was ahead of his time he
was talking about using your longest
weapon against your opponent nearest
point and we see that that that kick
that um
it
it got popular popularized by jon jones
you know the the sidekick to the time
it's longest weapon against your nearest
point in boxing is the jab but in mma
when you can use it all your weapon
that's the kick to the tie
and
there is
i feel there is like kind of three
dimension in martial art there is the
philosopher like bruce lee
there is the correct choreography the
choreograph
people like for example you see in
movies the stunned people they're
incredible like or the one that does
like forms and karate like jumping spin
kick bad kick like acrobatic stuff mixed
martial art they are unbelievable and
there's also the the
the one that compete in fighting like
that's what i do that i personally
specialize in well you also do the
philosophy i do a little bit of
philosophy but that's
you know consequence we are all i guess
we are all ever like we all practice the
three dimension because
martial art is i would say it's it
whether you want it or not you have to
touch these three dimensions
but you will specialize in one i
specialize to my life in fighting like
the real thing in terms of fighting
competition
and of course if you do martial art
you'll be able to defend yourself
because it's a self defense however you
might not be able to fight as an elite
and the most prestigious organization
and you might not be able to perform the
stunt that for example the stuntmen have
done in in the the syriza was playing in
the falcon and winter soldier these guys
are incredible they're like real life
superhero things they do it's to me
like it's it's fascinating it's amazing
and also bruce lee the philosophy
how many hours he
he took like
thinking about this stuff you know i'm
sure he did not just came out of out of
nowhere you know like he was thinking
like that's mean he slept on on this
he
how many hours it's just unbelievable
he's like water my friend exactly how
many times has he thought about water
going to bed yeah before he said that uh
well let me ask a very important
fundamental question about martial arts
we're both wearing a suit and tie
uh joe rogan thinks that wearing a tie
is a huge disadvantage
is it a clip-on or is it an actual tie
are you controlled by another one
so do you agree or disagree with joe
rogan that wearing a tie is a is a
martial art
significant disadvantage
in terms of combat in a combat scenario
in a fight i think it would be a
dissonant disadvantage yes okay but i i
work as a as a security bouncer in
nightclubs and event when i was 18 years
old yes
and um
sometime i had to work in certain event
that i was in suit and tie
i never had to
use
my force to take someone out when i
wasn't super untie but if i would have
had to before going to the table to
physically take the guy out i would have
removed my tie and i would have removed
my vest for sure and i would have called
back up for sure
and i would have probably used the
element of surprise to
be first on the guy yes
uh when you're in a bar same thing you
call back up first
and and and you make sure you ask the
way the waitress before to clean the
table before you go yeah and when you go
you have to use the element of surprise
yeah
because fighting
fighting that makes martial and fighting
in the street it's two different things
and yes i'm a mix i'm a mixed martial
art competitor that's what i've done all
my life but i had a lot of street fight
in my life a lot when i was in what's
the difference what's like that oh my
god it's a huge difference
there is guys that
if i would have a choice
you know to fight like for example
certain guys and you have seen a street
fight and fight
like other guys that are not in ufc i
would maybe sometimes pick guys that are
not in ufc not necessarily because in in
in a street fight there's no referee
that says go it's the element of
surprise and when you're a nice guy
you're not the aggressor
you always have the element of surprise
that's what it taught me oh interesting
yes because
if
aggression in your second person will
not come punch you without warning it
needs to it needs to trigger some it's
something need to be triggered before
so if someone comes because he's looking
for trouble
there's a sign that is looking for
trouble
so i was just talking with fast food and
this weekend about it and i saw that
every every martial art yeah
comes from like some martial arts are
from exclusive week for competition yes
like sport karate uh
like certain martial art but traditional
martial art are for the street are for
self defense
and i start my background in kyokushin
karate so it's for and and i did
japanese jiu jitsu so my background
before i even start
training for mixed martial art my
background is in self defense
and it's very important to understand
that in a street fight the element of
surprise is everything and there are no
rules you can go for the eyes the necks
it surprises everything
total ball game you know what i mean you
have the the chair the beard there's so
much more thing going on
so the idea of
because you are a ufc fighter you think
you're invincible this is bs
anybody can come like if if a big guy
who punched very hard most people don't
know how to punch by the way they don't
know how to make a fist and throw it in
a forward direction but if someone knows
how to do it i don't care who you are if
you could be francis and genu someone
come behind your head and
whang or
there's an argument and you get
surprised by a punch you can beat you up
and lose a fight that doesn't matter
yeah the element of surprise is
everything so you were saying remove all
the sources of the elements the surprise
all the
clear the bar remove the tie i still
disagree with you about the tablet
just for your information if someone
comes
looking for trouble and you see me do
this
and and going sideways yeah that's my
position that i'm i'm thinking there you
go maybe something will happen and i'm
about that's
see to flip the table on you then
wearing a tie
is communicating the nice guy image so
it actually gives you the freedom for
more elements of surprise by wearing the
tie if you take it off that's more
you're limiting your options because
nobody's going to expect the guy in the
tie to do anything i'm a big believer
that sometimes it's not only
materialism
it's what you project that's true like i
had troubles in a bar
and i was able to deflect
the guy was looking for trouble talking
to me and i was able to deflect his
whole aggressivity by saying like
hey man that's a nice shirt where did
you get it
like saying like something was stupid
like this then it it kind of break break
the momentum and he you know but the guy
was looking for trouble i don't want to
fight you
i don't want to fight you but i'm not
going to wait
until you pull you make the first move
because the first the minute you you
touch me you push me or you you touch me
you declare war and the war is unleashed
my friend and i'm i'm taking you out of
order with the necessary force of course
you know i mean that's
the thing with martial art if you use
the necessary force to take out a
problem
it's okay but if you
you know you you take advantage of it
that's when it's not all right because
it's a weapon
so if someone comes up to me
that's my position and now i'm i'm
assessing the situation you know
that's that's how they teach in self
defense here never put your hands down i
wasn't there
because i'm brown or boom like like what
this is this is
very important and you never
you always your center line on the side
ah yeah
like this if someone knows martial art
he will recognize that pattern but if
you go like if someone talk to you and
you go like this
that's mean you're telling the guy that
you want to fight you don't want to do
that you don't want to oh yeah um that's
that's interesting you know that's
that's the position because your hands
are here you know whatever you can do
you're here well also your ear tells the
story
it's not everybody that knows that
however it some people might might think
that it's my mom grabbed me by the air
and pulled me because i didn't listen to
her you know
a real fight in the stream and a fight
in in mixed martial is a different ball
game
what do you think is the best martial
art to prepare you for street fighting
you know people often kind of have this
discussion of jiu jitsu maybe boxing
maybe wrestling
do you think
when you talk about a young person
studying martial arts to prepare
themselves for um a street fight
it's often much different than a mixed
martial art fight
and
i know there is a lot of bs in the world
of martial art like self defense stuff
that like but
i believe
self defense is is very important in a
way to understand
the the situation to understand those
those
situations that might accurate how to
deal with it because not necessarily the
the
we talk about the technicality we talk
about the tacticality the tactics you
know like when i'm talking to you about
the element of surprise it's important
this is not technique a technique is a
punch or or
techniques that i physically will use to
enable my my my opponent my my aggressor
tactic is the tactic i'm telling you
about is in a street fight if someone is
looking for trouble and i feel the heat
rising as the conversation goes that's
the position i'm gonna take and
i have to be first
i cannot let him go first so i have to
strike first or do something this is the
first thing that generally and i have to
to
to agree on
um
after that of course there is the the
knowledge if you're a professional
fighter you have a
huge advantage once the fight is started
the war is declared now it's everything
goes
but
generally speaking the person that will
intervene physically that will have the
first blower the first you know the
first punch
will have a huge disa use advantage it's
like doing a 100 meter race and having a
head start you know and and that you
don't you can't prepare for with any
martial arts yeah and if i'm a smart guy
i know how to fight if a guy like uh
an heavyweight champion comes to me or
like like like a
you know i know i know what to do to
this this ebola like boom or hair and or
the neck you know like and if you
if you blind them what is it going to do
you know what i mean
so so or a bottle you know what i mean
so so the element of surprise is it's
everything so that's why it's always
always good to be the nice guy and not
looking for trouble because if you're
not looking for trouble
you have the head start you have the
option of having a head start so what
you're saying is being a nice guy is the
is the best form of self-defense maybe a
little humor
yeah
you know i have learned that i've
learned that when i was a kid yeah i was
about
maybe seven
six six years old we used to to play in
montreal there's a lot of snow we used
to play king of the mountain yeah
that's the first combat lesson that i've
learned in my life
and i managed somehow it was a lot of
kid i managed to get on the top of the
mountain and uh
another guy came come in on the top of
the mountain and he was angry that
before
i was there before him and
when you played king of the mountain it
was a mountain of snow you don't strike
each other we just wrestle and push and
i managed to be first and when he came
he says to me say
okay you wanna you wanna fight and i
said yeah i don't know what it means
like i wanna fight you wanna wrestle you
say i i say yes
he punched me right in the face boom and
then i and then i fall on on the bottom
of the mountain but then i when i fall
down
i remember that vision in my life
because it it it's it's
i will remember that for the rest of my
life
i'm about to stand up and i see the
blood coming out of my nose see the the
snow is red because my nose is bleeding
now i i remember
the element of surprises everything
my first street fight i've lost i got i
didn't get knocked out but i i got
dropped on the bottom of the snow
mountain and i was like uh he got me
because i was not expecting my hand i
was not expecting a punch
so from there when i felt the the the
eat of an in during an argument or
something was not right i always stroke
first
i didn't win all my fight because
sometimes there were more than one guys
on on me you know
but
i think it's important
to not be the aggressor so you have the
element of surprise and i always use
that in your favor that's so brilliant
let me uh go from the very practical to
the the most impractically huge question
about the meaning of life you said that
uh when great
depths
of unrelenting sorrow punctuated by
great peaks of joy and liberation
the result is delicious
so uh what do you think is the meaning
of this whole
journey that we're on this life what
makes life delicious
to me
you know
satisfaction is
the end for me like like i always
if i'm satisfied that's mean i have no
nothing to live for
i'm talking i'm not talking only about
my career about talking about my life
what i what do you want in your life you
want you want kids you want a family you
want to be champion what do you want in
your life you have like a long-term goal
short-term goal
in mixed martial art i achieved what i
needed to achieve
i'm sad cespar
i'm no longer the same josh schneider
than when i was on begging for a title
shot on my knees
i move on for it from it
now i had a chance to go into movies
now that same
insane
that same insane
drive that i had to be
the champion in the world now i put it
into acting
like i'm having a lot of acting class
now and luckily for me
the timing was amazing i got i got
casper the the falcon and the winter
soldier was that is on disney plus
channel
it's a huge huge project to be part of
for me because it's like
you play basketball you have a chance to
go for the nba right away i was very
lucky
the timing was just too perfect
and so
you need to constantly
challenging yourself and having goals to
achieve you know like that keep your
brain
activated i keep working
and the proof of that is that
you see sometimes some old people
like when they retire very often
sometimes you see that they they got
sick and they die or because they they
it's either because sometimes we think
we we
we certainly make benefits
we do something good for them by
making not work and giving them a break
so in our mind we're like oh it's gonna
be able to relax
but
in their mind it's not good because
they're not busy they have nothing to
live for like like my dad is used to
work all the time and he has always
something to do
is retire now
i myself now
call him by force to find him some job
hey dad okay
can you come in my house have this thing
to repair i don't know how to do it so
he gives him it gives him a reason not
not to live on because he has other
things to do but but
what i mean is also in life i think
you always don't be afraid to aim high
don't don't be afraid to fix your
objective very high and never be able to
reach it
be afraid of reaching your goals
essentially i mean you always have to
keep moving it out you think there's a
it's an interesting question because
you've been acting in some really
exciting things
do you think there's a a dramatic role
where
it's basically
you know you go full robert de niro and
taxi uh driver do you think they'll be a
full length feature film with george st
pierre i
liken there's level to this thing i'm
aware that i have to restart as a white
belt
and for some people it could be
discouraging but for me man it's great i
love it i freaking love it i embrace it
because everybody told me like i would
never be able to do it and it's fine
but
the and also the outcome of a failure
in the sport of mixed martial art is
much more serious
than the outcome of a failure for a
movie for example for for if you zig
when you shoot zag in a fight you get
knocked out if you zig when you shoot
zagging on set oh cut we'll do it again
and
i know that i will be most likely
be
chosen for action martial art roles
because that's my background there is
this new trend in hollywood now when
they want someone to play
an italian guy they're gonna choose a
real italian person when they want
someone to play a russian guy they're
gonna choose someone who has a real
russian background
now they want a real martial art fighter
i've done fighting all my life i just
need to improve my acting skill
but when i train in acting
i get myself out of my comfort zone i'm
not playing a role of a martial argument
i'm playing like romance comedy drama
so when i go on set and playing
the role of uh of a badass martial art
guy it's it's easier so like in training
for a fight i always make my preparation
harder than the actual task i would love
to see where i don't know if you've seen
the wrestler with uh mickey work
oh yeah those types of films i would
love to uh i would love to you do
something like that
if not now then in 10 20 years i could
see that that would be amazing there's
levels to the game right yes it's
gradual and i don't and i'm aware that i
i don't want to take something on my
shoulder that i won't be able to deliver
it's like a fighter wants to go for a
title shot right away could it could
very well break him
you know what i'm and i don't want to do
that because i know
i've done some gigs in the past but i
was not focusing on it because i was
focusing on competing as a martial art
martial artists and competition in mma
but now i take it very seriously so i
cannot do the same mistake again because
i've done some stuff i've done it for
the money and it was good
it was fun to to to be beat up by jacob
van damme
and everything but but my acting
was not on point you know at that time
so if i ever every time i'm gonna come
back from now on on on screen
you need to be sharp because you cannot
mess it up if you mess it up it's like a
loss on your record
you're not taken seriously
so so that's how i see it and
it's very fun because i i had a chance
to talk to a lot of guys and on top of
all the class that i'm having
like a few days ago i was with dani
trujo
and i i always seek the advice of actors
when i when i see some of them that
because i really admire how they do you
know how they project their emotion and
i asked him danny true i said i said to
him he is an amazing guy by the way very
nice guy
and i asked him i say him how
how do you do to be
because you scared the hell out of me
how do you do to be so scary like what
is your trick
and he tells me he's like george if
you're threatening if you threat someone
and you scream at him
i'm gonna kill you wherever
it's not as scary if you're smiling and
you say
i'm gonna kill you
like and he says also to me that another
advice he gave me is like when you say
this
think about you killing him for real
that how you hate him and how you gonna
kill him so the camera will take the
emotion out don't try physically to do
that that's the mistake i used to do
before i used to physically show that
i'm strong and angry and and to be mean
so these are the just an example of
tricks that i
learned sometimes when i met an actor i
always try to learn from everybody that
i met in my life it's a difficult
journey because then you have to go to
some dark places as a person because you
really have to imagine
imagine some dark things
that's fascinating actually i i think a
lot of the actors they have
sometimes problems because of that beca
because now i understand why it's like
if you work on your bicep your by itself
will grow right it's a it because it
it it's that stress that you put on it
that will make it grow right
emotions are i believe are the same way
if you're used to
dig inside of you down deep to to to to
make your negative emotion
depressive emotion comes out
if something
bad in your life happen you will fall
into those emotions much more rapidly
that's someone who does not that every
day you know what i mean because it will
it's like a muscle memory like if you
program yourself to react a certain way
you will reach that point very often so
that's why sometimes you see some some
guys they
we often blame it on drugs but i think
it's also because of the acting they are
used to be so
on the hopped up and sometimes they go
to the down deep so they
they they're they they're both extreme
you know you got to be psychologically
tough and that's life this is so
exciting to see you challenge yourself
in that direction
that's one thing that i'm a
a little bit afraid
that happened to me i i i really hope
i'll i'll always be uh
you know like a problem having a problem
to control my emotion be oh yeah much
extreme
i hope it does not happen to me and and
if i feel that i'm going towards that
i'm going to you know give up on on my
new objective and find something else to
to achieve
but in your personal life you want to be
real with your emotions you don't want
to it doesn't you know you're just just
like with biceps you don't want biceps
that are too big you you are real but
you
are extreme really and and that's that
that's the
that's what i think something that could
happen to actors sometimes when they go
too much into their emotion like we talk
about like sometimes guys that that that
commit commit suicide perhaps you know i
don't know it's because i don't know
their real life but it could be
something that
they get so much into their character i
didn't understand it at first because i
never had acting class but after a while
that you have acting class now you start
to realize that yeah okay you understand
why some actors get
caught up in their emotion because
that can have an influence on their life
right
you're on a fascinating journey uh
george i can't tell you how much it
means to me that you'll be so nice to me
that you'll give me so much respect just
that that tells everything i need to
know about you as a human being with
everything you've accomplished
you waste all your time and you're so
nice
to me just as a fellow human being man i
have so much respect i'm so honored and
the energy you give me by just even
showing up here i'll carry that forward
for a long time to come george i love it
thank you so much for talking today now
thank you lex for having me on the show
you know i've been looking to talk to
you for a long time
for me talking to a guy like you it's a
it's a great learning experience because
i always learn
and uh it's life is fascinating to me
and
all the experience that we have and
lives you know it's something that can
make us grow and this experience for me
just you know make me grow as a as well
you know plus we look pretty damn sharp
today so man and black my friend
thanks george
nice
thanks for listening to this
conversation with george st pierre and
thank you to all form expressvpn
blinkist theragun and the information
check them out in the description to
support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from miyamoto musashi
think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the world
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you